Hi, Baudry Flay. What do you think of it, Mrs. Flay? Do you want to imagine it, Mrs. Flay?
Oh, Brie Flay! I can't do that, but...
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Ooh.
I need a check.
It's very hard to pivot the camera to...
I'm not piloting a mech. I'm a real VTuber, by the way. I'm a real VTuber.
I will not admit I'm piloting a mech, even though I might be.
Hi, Reefling. You see me? You hear me?
I'm talking to the Baudry Flings, don't mind me.
Hi! Can you hear me?
No, I've not got any background music or anything on purpose.
I can put something there if you want.
Can you see the outline of your pintas?
No, I can't see. This is the webcam, so yes, there's a shadow cast.
I can't do anything about it.
What interests the nail colour scheme? What does Analyze the colours for no particular reason?
Hmm. Look at that green and purple.
Hmm. Curious. Green and purple.
Hmm. What does it mean?
What does it mean? We don't know.
Okay. Are you ready?
Time to put it on!
Here's my good Reefling.
Are you ready?
Hmm. Well, I'll put it on you.
What do you think?
I think it looks really awesome.
I'll put you on that.
Reefling!
Where'd you say go? That's right, you're getting me. Good.
Oh wait! But wait!
Bailey May is here with a special TV offer.
But wait! There's more!
Hold on.
If I can get it open.
I can't get...
Okay, you know what it is.
I can't get it open.
Come on.
I want this.
Very loud in my ear hole.
Okay, there we go.
I did it. I got it.
You think I should have done that before I started the stream, instead of during?
Are you ready for your training?
Did you see my streams this week where I'm turning in our puppy dogs?
I already got all the accessories for you.
Hmm.
Let's wait a little bit.
Are you ready for your training?
Yeah.
Woof woof woof.
Oh dear.
Put a little kibble in here.
Make it go in here.
Make it eat them.
Looky looky.
I got my corporate, got my tea.
My British fucking tea.
This is the tea that always goes cold, okay?
It always goes cold.
Can I, am I allowed to talk to you whilst looking my tea?
Hmm, yeah, this is pretend we're doing Lego ASMR.
She came showing me, look.
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo.
Sorry, it's falling out at the bottom, but don't mind me.
You can't see that.
Okay, I'm a funerfmucky.
I'm still wearing pants on the stream these days.
I had to put clothes on.
I'm repping the merch.
Look at me, it's two of me actually, so honestly, this next character, she matches my color scheme quite well.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, yeah, the training to be a dog to turn you into him.
You have to wait for the tea.
Okay, so this is how much tea we have, so let me begin.
Oh, let me be clear, oh my god, yes, we're doing Hobbit, an unexpected journey, okay?
And then, who do we have on the box?
We've got Big Gandalf, we've got Big Bilbo, his hair is perfectly nice, lovely, who did that?
Hold on, let me get out of the way, let's admire the box, no one's here for, oh, just spilled tea all over me!
Right, put the fucking lego away and drink the tea first, you fucking twat.
Right, that's it, you need to look at that, literally.
Hmm, nice warm tea, who wants to suck the tea from my leggings?
You're more than welcome to, no, no, no, help yourself, Riefling, you mean, take it all, take it all.
Oh yeah, that smells good.
Me, yeah, you're always sucking up.
I'm doing the lego in a minute, give me a minute, give me a minute, this tea's gonna be frozen, okay?
Let it go, let it go, did you just see my hair?
Oh wait, sorry, I'm ginger and green hair in real life.
Shadow Wizard Money Gang, we destroy VTubers in this house.
I'm not piloting a mech, I promise I'm not piloting a mech.
Mummy, close her rip, better take them off, are they absorbing at least, can you absorb?
I can't believe it, my Strony branded merch, well, it's just, it doesn't, uh, oh.
I'm gonna wipe myself down cause you're not sucking fast enough.
Yeah, look, rip, check the nails, stunning, gorgeous.
I got the boss lady but she didn't recognise me, obviously I was gonna throw it all out, I was like, give me back my toenail.
But no, she wasn't in the talking mood and I was like, thank god cause I don't talk in general.
And my voice is still broken from the Elden Ring stream, you might be able to hear it right now, it's possible, but yeah.
I broke my voice on Elden Ring with you, but that's okay, that's my fault.
So I'm shutting up after this stream.
I've got five pre-made shorts that I'm gonna record after stream, I think.
And then that's it, I'm not allowed to talk, I'm not allowed to do any calls, management or anything like that.
Um, yeah, the, if you want some leaks, there's not really many leaks going on right now.
We're kinda at the stage where the leaks are like, you can't leak that yet, but you can leak it once it's leaked.
And I'm like, okay, okay, so I'm praying Shibi just starts leaking stuff and then I can leak it too cause Shibi has to do it.
I can't do it, that's not, I'm not allowed to take that away from the girl, okay.
I need, I need Shibi to leak it.
I'm being like, am I in a suspended accident?
Me like, no, I can finally talk about it, thank god.
Speaking of leaks, oh, did, did Zora do Peeler?
Leaking the leak is peaking, is there a reason your pinky isn't perfect?
Yeah, yes there is, but that reason I cannot leak it.
I wonder, I wonder why my nails are arranged in such a way.
You've already reached your leak budget for this quarter, honestly, I genuinely have.
Hi, Stroni has been going, I'm finishing my cup of tea, look, look how much I drank, I'm such a big girl.
Look, it's getting like, it's 3D, ooh, 3D cup of tea.
And yes, there's a bird on the side that goes, what's doing?
Don't you know about the bird?
Everybody knows the TikTok bird.
That's a bit of brain rot for you.
3D debut, fucking hell, how much money do you think I have?
3D debut, mm.
I'm a confidently say no, but thank you, I love the enthusiasm.
Colours indicate what she does with a finger.
Oh, you've not heard of this move, yeah, have I not done this move against you?
I call it the prostate piercer.
What the hell is this?
What would these three come together to do?
That looks awful.
I look like I'm trying to throw up gang signs but fail in a really bad way.
I'm like, fail in the dexterity check.
How do you put 3D together?
Doing the wooshy finger fold.
So you know that.
Oh wait, no, what is it? Is it skiddish?
Like that, skiddish?
Any skiddishers?
Any skiddishers at all.
Okay, let me finish this.
And me did what?
When?
No, she didn't.
You're trolling, right?
I don't know, are you skidding me?
Is it feel, what?
Sorry, hold on, let me read again.
Is it bad if you're slightly more anxious when I'm separated?
Is it bad though?
I mean, if I can bring you comfort when I'm up but I don't want you feeling bad when I can't be online all the time.
Like this week is a very short week but I'm needing it because I'm trying to, I've just got the audio manager in.
I'm going to try and get another manager in so then I am fully just a creative,
I write scripts if they want them, I do stuff if they want them but I'm only on the creative side.
I don't tell them any agents.
This is the girls, okay?
This is me not doing anything for them and breaking it down.
Separation anxiety is normal.
As long as we have separation anxiety, oh my, I can't be online all the time, I feel bad.
I might have a, I'm trying to think that I might have that unique level.
I could potentially do it today, I know I keep saying I'm going to do it tonight or today
but what happens is I go offline and I've got eight DMs and I'm like, I have to deal with all of this right now.
Right now.
And then I get very tired.
Okay, let me finish this.
Let's see, look at my, look at that progress.
Look at that 3D debt.
That's okay.
We know you need your rest unfortunately.
As I said, if I was a vampire, it'd be over for everyone.
We know you mummy, you probably have things planned for net.
No!
Why would I do that?
Why would I have things planned?
Where's my ruler?
Hold on, hold on.
Whoa, just like the webcam.
I'm doing my face with you.
You know I look brash.
Where's my ruler?
Hello?
Where's the open end?
Oh God, wait, I can bring my January.
Oh, hold on.
Hold on, bring in January, come on.
January is watching me build Lego.
Against their will.
Ooh, you see that?
I didn't like it.
You heard that?
Mate, come on then.
You're forced to watch me build Lego.
Oh, but I don't want to.
Well, I don't want to do a lot of things and I still do.
I still do, so you have to come along.
Come along.
Oh my God, the other racist agency, they whitewash their talents.
And they're merchandise.
That's it, the other, you're getting cancelled on Twitter right now.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it the way you've been doing these things.
Sorry, I don't know what the fuck I'm yapping about.
I'm trying to finish this cup of tea.
Oh my God, my hair is on the thing already.
Get over here.
And then obviously, I don't know, are you kidding me?
I look forward to the Patreon later.
Wait, what happens on Patreon?
Hold on a minute.
Oh, the punk audio role play.
Okay, thank you Dynan for 10 pound meal deal at M&S.
I uploaded a Patreon audio and I'm a punk in it and I'm like, hey, you mister,
I don't have a place to stay the night.
What?
No, I don't want your money.
I want Shellr and I'm a punk.
And in the role play, I have two angel wings.
But in real life, I only have one.
I only have one.
Actually, my angel wings are the funeral for me.
Just in case you haven't seen that.
Let's hold a lot of velour funeral for it.
Let's hold a funeral for it.
Okay, so this is me crying next to the angel wing.
And then, yes, I'm role playing with my gen mates with fucking key chains.
No, this is funny.
I'm having a funeral.
Right, mercy.
My hair's too big, unfortunately.
I have to go here a little bit.
Shibi.
Shibi, would you like to say a word because you are also peers?
Ash, you twerk.
I am so saddened at your angel wing being gone.
I'm so sorry it happened so.
And then, A.C. will come and comfort me.
And then, Imi will massage my feet, thank you.
And then, Azura will play with my hair.
And then, Mercy will give me his kisses.
And then, Shibi will suck me off under the desk.
That's how the girls are going to comfort me.
Right, enough, enough, enough shenanigans.
But, if you ever wanted your own, it would be a market key chain of any of the girls at the beginning.
You know where it goes.
The link is in the description.
Yeah, I don't know if you guys are comfortable with this concept,
but I thought, from a doughnut on the top, Donator would get my crusty angel wing.
And before you're like, wait, Strawny, what do you mean crusty?
I mean, literally, there's crust embedded in this little thing.
This used to run through my skin and it doesn't.
Yeah, that's how the pierced thing is.
Oh, God, I can't.
What? That was my stomach that made that noise.
Have you heard that?
There you go.
It did me a good server.
It did good, but I'm not getting re-pierced before anyone asks
because it was so painful and terrifying.
And the healing process was genuinely awful.
Absolutely awful.
Sending a chemical weapon to your top Donator is a vote.
For real.
Okay, now let's actually get down to that agenda.
Oh, the manual just fell out.
Emanuel.
Come on, Stan.
Okay, so we've got buffer.
Bumper, I'm pretty sure.
Hold on.
I'm a fake Hobbit fan.
Let me just...
Gandalf the Grey, Feldo Baggins, Bolin.
I don't have my glasses on and this is Tiny.
Hold on a minute.
We've got Dolin, Buffer and Bumper.
Okay.
Why all the Bs?
I guess I'm missing one.
Yeah, this is my Lego Hobbit set.
I didn't even think I was gonna get this.
I just looked up the price of it and it was like,
obviously come on manual.
I've never built Lego in so long.
Oh, they gave you this.
There's like this special magical piece
that's like gonna separate the...
You wear glasses?
Yeah.
This is my glasses when I play Fortnite.
Glasses to the enemies.
Look, they're child's glasses
because adult glasses don't fit my head.
I don't know what's wrong with my head,
but I can only fit child's glasses.
So there you go.
These are me.
Okay, I'll put my glasses on for the shoot.
Whoa, I can see.
Cute, extra small and cute head.
Literally, I was really embarrassed getting glasses.
I was like,
where's for the women's?
You know, where's for the adults?
And I was like, I can do this one.
It's kind of adorable.
It needs to be carried around in a pocket.
Like a pocket.
No, you can't say that, right?
I can't wear the glasses
because my brain's trying to adjust.
I'm still not adjusting my glasses.
Okay, so long story short.
This cost a lot of money
and thank you to the Anon,
that literally...
Why is there pieces?
It's a resale, by the way.
This is like old, old.
But do you want to hear the drama?
The drama?
Okay, you want to know where the drama was?
I got sent a fake Lego set.
Everyone gasped at the same time.
A fake Lego set.
But I got full refund, so don't worry.
Sorry.
So the company I bought from got scammed.
This is the second box.
Sorry.
It looks like I've just pulled out the same box.
No, I've got two.
And they gasped.
So it got delivered and I heard it
and I was like, this does not sound right.
And then I don't know if you can see.
This is very clearly opened.
Like I didn't do this like tab business thing.
And then the set.
I don't want to get it mixed up by accident.
The set is the wrong fucking color.
I'm like, who's Lego is this?
It's like part three of some other set.
It's all red.
This is not Hobbiton.
I don't know what this is.
And yeah, like this is all black.
I'm like, what or who, why?
Bizarre.
But I've got full refund, so happy days.
They also gave me the Hobbit advertisements
for like all the different Hobbit sets
being my bobbers.
But I don't really care too much
for anything else.
I was in Bag End and Hobbiton.
I just want to Hobbiton or Bag End.
I want like a full ass set.
You know how like everyone's like,
oh, you should do the, um, how do you call it?
Oh, these are extra Lego pieces
in case they go missing.
Oh my gosh, I can push stickers then.
Oh my God, that's so cute.
I can put like wood on the Bag End.
It must be.
We will follow the instructions at once.
Oh, right.
Let me make my VTuber model a little bit smaller,
because I am, I think it's over.
Right.
I've not done Lego.
Oh, they sent an extra piece as well.
Thank God, because by the way,
if I had to take pieces apart with these nails,
it would be over.
The stream would never end.
It would be the endless stream, honestly.
Right, let's just put these away,
because this one says number one.
Okay, so let's start there.
Let's start in number one together.
We are building sideways.
So we're building...
Wait, what?
Is this the bag?
Oh, no!
Oh, yeah.
There's two booklets,
so that's how long this is going to take.
Are we going to finish in one stream?
I'm getting nervous.
Are we going to be able to finish this style?
I'm starting to think this isn't going to be a one-off stream.
Um, right, let's take a piece number one.
Okay, piece number one.
Let's do a speedrun.
I think I would have to literally stop looking at chat
if I was going to try and do a speedrun.
Right, we've got another orange,
which is actually probably pretty handy.
I can see myself doing the wrong thing.
I can't put my digital model anywhere else.
So this is how the track is going to be.
It's just going to have to get lost a little.
Is there an S?
Whoa!
Wait, the box is called S for that time?
It says it's for 94-year-olds.
14-year-olds, right?
All right, so that means if I have enough brain power,
I can do those rank work.
With the yapping.
Oh, there's another packet inside the packet.
These were put...
That's Bilbo's hair!
They killed my man!
Where's Bilbo?
Bilbo!
He's dead!
No, we packed it.
Oh, no.
Where's his body?
Bilbo?
Are you in here?
Bilbo.
Oh, I see his face.
What the fuck?
Why are we unlocking my characters one part by part?
A typical nation.
Thank you for the tip.
You can use the orange tool to help you place the stickers more neatly.
Oh, okay.
It means you're not legally allowed to build it
until after the age of 14.
Surely this isn't going to be hard.
Right, okay, let's get the facts right.
Okay, so I'm going to try and do it so you can see
both the manual and the Lego we're working on.
So I'm going to have to look away from the microphone a little bit for this.
Okay, so here's the instructions.
Here's the pile of shite we're working with.
That's about eight.
Step one, take the plank and add a long green strip.
Surely this is how it's meant to be, right?
Hold on.
I'm going to see if I can eliminate this area slightly there.
I do have not really, um, if you really know,
so you should be perfectly, look,
you should have a very nice thing you can see.
Uh, whoa, that's too much.
Okay, sorry, that's too much.
Sorry about that.
She's not getting fucking blinded watching this stream.
Uh, the green piece goes next to it, not on it.
Whoa.
What?
Green.
That one.
What, like that?
Are we extending?
And then it gets held together by four wee skinny ones in a row.
I have access to four wee skinny ones in a row.
No, I don't.
I don't see it.
Is it in these?
It's not told me to open.
Oh, there's a skinny one.
I need those, mate.
It's in here.
I guess you are opening these ones.
Give me Bilbo.
I got the dirty one.
I'm going to do this with the animals.
Right, okay.
Okay, so before, are we all a great dish on my face?
She's stumbling on step one.
Don't point it out.
I'm trying.
I don't know how well you can see the instructions, but yeah.
A little skinny piece goes up here.
Okay, extend it and then add this.
How do we do it on four?
It must be on the floor.
I was going to say you can't do that.
Okay, so four pieces will extend to the plate area.
Okay, we're expanding the map.
The next, take the eight dotted green pieces
and walk.
Add them down.
One, two.
What the fuck?
No, I should have watched the video.
You know that?
I'm so confused right now.
I'm not even like...
I'm not even trolling.
I think I need to use your glasses.
No, it's not that.
I don't know.
I'm here, right?
I've just done this one.
And then it says take a piece like this, which I have.
It takes multiple pieces.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, okay.
I'm supposed to do it this way.
Sorry, I didn't have my glasses on.
Sorry.
Okay, just put them together.
Sorry, sorry.
That makes much more sense.
Yeah, they're obviously going to have lines in the diagram
that you can see, but you can't visually see them.
If you're being blinded by a ring light, okay?
Be nice to me.
I'm being blinded by a ring light.
Stop.
Right, okay.
Step three, completo.
Okay, first page done.
What's next?
Okay.
Next is take a sand, a ground block.
You do what was it?
Oh.
Take a block and then do what?
Just do that.
And then put a big green quadrant on top.
My paternal urge to take care of...
I'm fucking dumb.
I'm so sorry.
Right, it says take that one.
Right, we've done that.
And this step says one, six green teeth.
Okay.
Then extend it to whole...
Yes, okay.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, step five done.
Oh my God.
Okay, I've got it.
I've got it.
Okay, then we're going to step six, which is this green teeth here.
Okay, it's starting to slowly understand my brain is catching up.
Very slowly.
I need a green teeth to hold.
And where does it...
What does this green teeth go?
Like that?
That's all that's left to do?
No.
Whoa, that's fucked up already.
Hold on a minute.
Let me just...
Oh, this one.
I forgot that.
It disappears, okay?
Okay, and then it goes like that.
And then...
And then what?
What?
Yeah, this is correct.
Hold on.
It's not over until it's over, you know what I'm saying?
One, two, three, one, two.
Three.
How many...
Four to three.
But three in the book.
Stranny, you need a three by two.
What?
Wait, is that a wheel?
Oh, it is a three by two!
How did you spot that?
You have such good eyes.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh...
Then a three by two.
Yeah.
Two.
Four.
And if I do that, then does it do the number thing I want to do?
Let's do...
Three.
What?
Hold on.
Nah, positive tunes.
What's going on here?
Something's no right, and it's probably me.
Right, what's going on?
Step one.
Right, step one.
Right, fuck off, not now.
Step one, add the sand block underneath, which we have, it's there.
That...
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, I need to justify it to you before we continue.
Hold on, positive tunes.
Add one sand block.
I have added the sand block, it's there.
This is this one.
Add one, four by two to keep the sand and the grass together.
Okay.
And then add one fucking circle thing.
So I'll put it there, the weights in the diagram.
And then it says one, three by two, all of a sudden, is producing...
What?
Oh, shit!
Oh, this looks great.
Whoa, we did it!
We did it!
I said, yeah, we did it!
We did it, we did it.
We're on step seven.
We did it!
Okay, page two complete.
I think I was trying to insert something where it shouldn't belong.
What does that mean?
What do you mean by that?
Okay, next step of this.
Are you ready?
Okay, step eight, take this, add it in here.
Gorgeous.
And then take one, two, three, four, five, six by two, which is this, and connect it here.
Okay.
Fucking hell, it's all blended in.
I hope none of you are colorblind.
Then take...
Where's my glasses?
Actually, I'll give it up and put my glasses back on.
All right, you win.
You win.
I'm wearing glasses in this room.
That doesn't help.
Is this room dark?
I'm having a mental...
Yeah, I'm losing it.
Anyway, this is why I wear the collar.
Okay, two, we won.
And then one, two, three, four, five, six, and one, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay, six by two, six by one, two, we know.
It's got it.
Six by two, one, two, three.
Yeah, six by two.
That's that piece there.
Okay.
Then a skinny six by one.
That's that piece there.
And then two wee jobbies inside.
Are the jobbies in here?
Oh, I see my jobbies.
Out comes.
I see my jobbies in here.
I've lost them.
Okay, one jobbie.
And then we need one more jobbie.
Oh my God.
Oh, it's Bilbo.
He's coming together.
Hello.
Oh, I dropped them.
Sorry.
I don't look so worried.
He's so scared.
He's like, no, they're reading my pantry.
What's up?
Right.
Unfortunately, it doesn't happen.
You ain't got no legs.
Lieutenant Dan.
Is this easier?
This is easier for me.
I'm going to be honest.
I can kind of bring the microphone
a little bit closer to me like this.
Okay.
I blew his legs off of C4.
Oh, there's his legs.
Oh my God.
I'm speaking of his legs.
Feel it.
Now he can shy.
I just had a memory.
There's a YouTube video
of Lego people
doing a drunk song,
but it's to a musical Mozart piece
or something like that.
It's like, drink to your family.
Drink it with your friends.
Beer of friendly liquid made for you.
You're going to drink till you spew.
Okay.
We have Bilbo.
Right.
Back to the problem.
Okay.
I need a skinny Joby, right?
Skinny Joby.
Come on.
Come to mommy.
I probably should have used
my headset for the stream.
Now that I think about it,
instead of the microphone
being a little to the ring,
I shouldn't have a headset on.
That would have sounded like this.
Right.
We've got the pieces for this bit.
This looks like that.
I'm not going to put it down
until I'm satisfied
with the structure in which
I'm going to put it down.
Not again.
Hold on.
I need to pick up the sheet paper.
I can't see the brown very well.
What a bizarre.
I don't know how it creates the Lego,
but sometimes it feels like
they don't want you to win.
I do it when they are.
Then I do a skinny pool
and then do a long.
And then I do skinny again.
Like that.
And then I hammer them all in.
Oh, I missed.
That's okay.
Hold on.
It's a bit.
Something's cracking.
I ain't me.
Must be your back.
Oh, Jesus.
Whoa.
Don't do that.
Please go in.
Thank you.
Oh, we're down there.
And then we need three tails
and two green.
So tail, tail.
Oh, don't do it.
Tail.
And then two green.
That's a light gray.
Not black.
So I can't see what it is.
Lego raking ASMR when?
Autistic girlfriend rakes through Lego
while you sleep ASMR when?
Where the fuck is it?
Huh.
Am I going mental?
Hold on a minute.
Oh, let me just slavix squat.
Oh, I found one.
I'm slavix squatting right now.
I don't know if you can tell.
Can you tell?
Those are my thanks.
I'm slavix squatting.
This is the perfect way to find the missing Lego.
Bro, how do you think you should?
Where's the green?
Yeah, I'm down.
If I can't find it.
I need one little green piece to continue.
I'll please tell them I've not lost a piece already.
That would be far too early.
Okay.
That would be far, far too early.
Where?
I'm gently combing over.
It's like super big.
Trouble.
Am I going?
I'm pointing with my finger.
I've actually lost a fucking piece already.
Okay.
Let's just put this down first.
So, in theory.
In theory, yeah.
Oh, you can tell where the big light is.
You're getting blinded in my string.
No, we're gamers out here.
We can't be gamers.
Where's the fucking...
Oh, there is.
Found it.
Okay.
Square has won.
We've all been poking out.
Like that.
I mean, it looks like...
Whoa, don't go that far.
Don't go that far.
Let me go get it.
Why did...
Have I done that wrong?
Wait.
Have I done that upside down?
Oh, excuse me.
Sorry.
Don't look at one set.
Don't look.
I'm embarrassed.
Don't...
I was like, no, that's not possible.
That's not how it works.
Just don't look.
I'm embarrassed.
Don't look.
It was upside down.
Okay.
I admit it.
I'm embarrassed.
This is going to take so long.
I bet you'll be like,
what's the average time it takes to build this set?
It'll be like two hours, me five hours later.
I did it.
Right.
Third page done.
Yeah.
And a whole other night.
Can we do the cute shit that's repetitive?
What is this?
What?
Hold on.
Let me...
Hold on tight.
You should have bridges.
That's good for Peach.
Go.
Okay.
Let's put this aside.
To the side, you go.
Okay.
So take a sand and a long strip of grass.
Which is what you're looking for.
Take a strip.
She's checking it twice.
I'm trying to see if you're nodding or not.
And I'm kidding.
It's not Christmas just yet.
But if we do celebrate Christmas with you...
Are you with me right now?
Oh no, ironically though.
Sorry, sorry to...
Sorry to go on a fucking round the way back.
It do be kind of feeling like Christmas is a day.
I was talking to a creator I might be so happy with shortly.
And I was kind of just like seeing...
Obviously it was very quick because I was getting ready for a stream at the same time.
I was just saying to her, I was like, I can just finally be myself, you know?
There's no...
There's no nothing.
There's no stress at all.
There's no worry of anything.
Okay, we're kind of...
I think it's clicking slowly in my head.
But I was just like every day is like a...
Autistic girlfriend builds Lego video...
Wait, didn't I not just say that?
What are you not here for?
I said I was gonna do a meme rule for you.
Autistic girlfriend's Lego building.
I'm gonna take another small green pack.
And I'm gonna connect those two pieces together.
And then take another corner piece.
Like this.
And then take a three by two.
Oh my gosh, it's clicking!
I'm just...
Well, sometimes I'm smart.
I'm not...
I am having a good time though.
I hope this isn't too boring.
I'm actually really enjoying this.
I didn't expect to enjoy it so much.
But I am.
She's doing it, Kendall.
Look, we're already on the next page.
I think it just needed to...
Because I've not built Lego before.
I see people do it.
I've seen like this.
I don't know if you remember this viral video where it was this poor gentleman crying.
Someone purposely came in and broke his stuff.
His Lego stuff.
It was truly the most bizarre timeline.
They were like so malicious against that poor man.
And they broke all his sets and everything.
And he was crying.
And he was like, I give up.
I'm not doing this anymore.
Very thankfully.
I think a couple of months later he came back to the Lego hobby.
But yeah, this is your first Lego.
Yeah.
I've never done Lego before.
Wait, is it really common to do Lego?
Um...
I...
I don't do...
I didn't have the opportunity.
I got forced like...
Did I tell you that time I chewed on marbles as a kid?
Because I was that dumb?
I don't know if I told that story yet.
Um...
Once upon a time...
I got gifted marbles.
And they were rainbow colored.
Um...
And I was convinced they were like those chewy hard candy sweets.
So I was like for five minutes I was like chewing on marbles.
I thought I was like those like hard sweets
that have that outside in there like gum in the middle.
So I was like chewing and chewing and chewing and chewing.
I just didn't give up.
I was kept going for like five minutes and munching on them.
So...
Yeah, and um...
So I...
Anyway, that's the true story.
Um...
And I have to live with that knowing I did that at my big old age of like...
I think I was nine...
I think I was ten years old actually.
Does Mummy have British teeth?
Sadly I spawned in with them.
Um...
But I'm really lucky.
I don't have...
You got it wrong.
Are you squidding me right now?
I don't know.
Excuse me, Mum.
We've had a few concerns raised by your fellow Hobbits in regards to your construction site.
Could we see your OSHA certification?
No, I don't have one anonymous.
Thank you for the tip.
I don't have one.
Oh wait.
I never saw...
Sorry.
I never heard the other gifted.
Do you want to know my setup right now?
This is how I...
If I know you have given me a super chat or something.
It plays out of this headphone and I have to listen out for that.
Are you squidding me right now?
I'm sorry if I missed any donations.
I'm shy.
Hold on.
Thank you basically for the tip as well.
Autistic girlfriend builds a Lego figure and puts it in her...
cursed Lego.
Curse.
This headset is too small for you.
I wish this thing could go smaller.
I used these blanks.
I used to use turtle beaches obviously.
Am I going crazy?
A wee bit.
I mean that looks great.
Take the long green one.
Take the long brown one.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Well.
Brown.
Green.
Yeah.
I don't know why my brain is telling me it's brown.
That's my body.
Where did that come from?
I'm connecting...
like this.
Oh my gosh.
It's going to be this.
Sorry my hair is fricking on the mat.
It's going to be this big.
It's a little bigger than I thought it was.
I thought it was going to be small.
Oh my God.
Look at that.
It took way too long to do just that.
Okay.
We need long brown.
One long brown.
Two long brown.
And then put them.
Oh my God.
This must be back in the house.
We're doing it.
Are you proud of me replaying?
You need to build on a hard surface?
I mean...
Just holding together quite well.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, you like that.
Look at this.
This is your bull sack stitching.
And this is my finger going up it.
Making that noise.
Okay.
I need two big blocks of sand.
And two corner pieces of sand.
That I have here.
And I am going to not do it upside down like last time.
I...
I am a surgeon.
Oh, you're my surgeon.
I'm a surgeon fish.
Push.
My little fingies are pushing down so hard.
Bro, she buffed up my fingers.
I don't even see it.
So at the end of doing your nails,
they like buffer fingers,
but I have really awkwardly shaped like nails,
beds or whatever.
She fucked my hood up.
Most lady was not having it.
Some other nice lady asked me
if I was getting beatled just nails.
And I was like,
honestly, it looks like it.
no, it's for an anime girl.
And I was like,
hey, I'm a small talk.
We're doing here.
I was like,
oh, you're my surgeon.
She was like,
And I was like,
oh, don't you get...
Wait, turn it upside down.
Oh my...
We're doing surgery.
I am a surgeon.
We're holding it together with butterflies.
A butterfly tape.
Okay.
We are.
Like this.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so smart.
Sometimes.
Oh.
Oh, give it what we feel.
What do you feel?
Diamond for M&As less.
I never heard this.
Brian, Brian,
you need to announce yourself louder.
Do you understand me, Brian?
Brian, don't give me that look.
Whoa.
That's a bit of a rough surgery.
But I think the patient's going to be okay.
I think he's going to be okay.
I'm not strong enough
to squeeze the leg pieces together.
Maybe turn the instructions.
Just an idea.
Make it easier on your side.
Don't take it in a bad way.
Wait, my don't...
It's better if you see it.
Or am I going mental?
It's better for you to see it.
But my bad.
Wait, am I being a dumb dumb?
If I'm looking at them up,
the instructions upside down,
it's still correct for me
if I have this bit upside down.
Or is that not how the instructions are?
I think universal.
Weird.
I picked you.
No, it's okay.
You're the one who does it.
Thank you, Diamond.
I did it.
Need a harder surface
so your chest will suffice.
You know what?
Take that.
I love my nails.
I feel so girly
when I get my nails done
because I'm not very girly at all.
What am I...
speaking of being a look
at the instructions a bit closer?
That doesn't really make any sense.
It just says kind of
what put one here.
I mean, yeah,
that's what it says.
Slip back.
No, I'm up here.
Oh, no.
Is it here?
Okay.
Okay, that's fitting really well.
Now we're turning it
and we're adding two,
four hills and two long ones.
Can I get four hills and two?
No, two hills and...
Oh, what?
Four hills and two long ones.
Sorry.
I mean, we're almost done
the first piece.
If we're going by the bag,
I've almost finished the bag,
the first bag,
and there's four.
So we're already one fourth
of the way there.
Right?
That's how it works.
Yeah.
I think it is.
So these graph versions
and then two of them.
Okay.
And then we put the graph verges.
That's the building
that's bag end.
So...
Now hold on a minute.
This is just to be a little gap.
No.
I almost fell
for the instructions mistake.
It says go one up.
Oh, my God.
I almost got pranked by Lego.
But anyway, speaking of Lego,
if you guys could come out with a bag end,
like a proper bag end set,
I'll buy it.
I don't care how much it costs.
Please cater to the nerds like me
who just like the fantasy garden
and just don't, you know,
want to get a little getaway,
want to do a little thing.
Mum is so smart.
Good job.
I actually do feel praised right now.
You know what?
I'm doing a good job.
Are you having fun?
I am, mama.
I'm having fun.
I am.
Okay.
We've got graph verges.
Oh, my God.
We're doing so good.
And then we need two long wee bits
and wee wee bits.
Okay.
Two long bits and two wee bits.
They're still small though.
Okay.
I got them.
Then the two long bits go here.
On the outer pieces of the
the board.
This is,
this is not chess board.
Actually, I need to,
that's like the third time I reset
I got chess board.
And I've not planned it this week.
I did.
And I made an account.
I'm telling you,
you're still yet to do it.
Who's going to be able to play
with me and Sheevie
on
Left or Dead?
I'll message Sheepsters to see how
a pat on the butt for how well I'm doing.
See no more.
Yes.
Me and Sheevie are playing
Left or Dead 2 together.
I'm so happy.
She like messaged me
and she was like,
oh, can I do it with you?
And I'm like,
I didn't even occur to me
that I could grab another girl
and bring her with me
to get stream sniped with me
so she can enjoy in the fun.
So I've been thinking
away at myself
if there's a possibility
of more stream sniping
with my gen mates.
But it has to be
on games that they are playing.
I'm not making anyone play games.
They're like,
oh, we're getting a bit advanced.
Hold on a minute.
I need one wee gray block.
Got it.
I need two long,
wait, what?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh, that's that one.
I need a wee four piece of sand.
And then I need two long ones.
And just to check.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Or should I be counting the other one?
And I have plans on my
didn't save the other reasons
I have to play.
Well, I was gonna,
I don't know how long Sheepsters
is gonna keep it up for.
I'm not gonna like force her
to keep playing things.
Think of the weaklings.
No.
But I can continue afterwards.
And you guys can show me the game.
Because I think we'll do
zombie mode to give as much people
a chance as possible.
But we are gonna...
I can't talk and think at the same time.
Let's start with the...
Let's start with the outside key.
Okay.
A true gentleman.
I can dance.
And what do you attach to?
There's nothing to you.
You don't attach to anything.
You're just there.
I assume my piece is gonna come along.
Um...
Hmm!
Ah!
Wait.
Hold on.
This is what happens when I get off of here.
Get out of here.
What?
Ah!
It was supposed to go back.
No!
Don't start this.
I'm not repeating anything.
Hold on.
What?
A campaign map can last an hour?
I was just gonna boot you after I go.
Like, after we finish our map, you'd get booted over.
Hold on.
Yeah.
One back.
Agreed.
I'm glad we're on the same page.
Right.
Let's try again.
Take the long piece.
Right.
Then take this boy.
See that boy?
See who he is.
He is that Lego block.
I swear.
He's that Lego block.
And then...
Right.
That.
Correct.
Correct him.
Correct him and do.
Right.
And then we need corner sandstone.
Two by one sand.
Two little brown things.
And then one long sand.
And then what?
Okay, the long one goes over here.
Good.
This is quite the set.
I wonder how much it retailed for when it actually came out.
Because I go, come on.
Because it was scalpers.
You told me that word yesterday.
It was scalpers.
Will someone please blame the scalpers?
They make all the prices so big.
And that's what they are.
They inflate it.
Yep.
They're into inflation, clean.
I'm not here at kink shing.
But if you inflate my Lego pieces,
I'm...
Right, go in.
Go in.
Who wouldn't go in?
That looks correct, right?
Oh my god.
Okay, nice page.
This is getting mighty complex through my brain.
I don't know about you,
but this is getting mighty complex.
Thank you, Stache Power.
For the tip as well.
Yes, I will boot you out after every lobby.
I think you're going to have to add me
on my Strony Snipes account in order to get in.
Because Shibi doesn't have a stream chat account.
I want to keep her account safe.
It's possible.
Right, I need one singular sand block.
You got any emeralds for me?
Okay, one singular sand block.
Two sandy slopes.
Sand to sandy.
Four by one sand.
Gimli's hair is somehow in the Lego pieces
when this is being unopened.
Gimli's my cat, by the way.
For content.
I have a cat called Gimli.
You named your cat after a Lego Lord of the...
Lego Lord of the Rings?
Yeah, fuck it.
I named her specifically after a Lego Lord of the Rings.
Okay, I need two brown slopes as well,
but it looks longer.
And then, a knee.
One, two, three.
I need to sit down still.
I'll gather them and then I'll apply them.
My fingers are getting sore.
They're like, this feels sore.
Gives it better replant.
Gives my baby there.
Are we going to focus?
Focus on it.
Ew, you hear transness in this scene.
Ew, don't look at the veins of my fingers, okay?
Don't be rude.
Don't stare at the veins in this scene.
Okay, thank you for kissing up there.
I didn't realize making Lego was sore on the hand.
Right, enough yapping.
Where or what am I doing?
Okay, take the long...
No, don't take the long two.
Hold on.
My brain is putting together what it's asking.
Right, it's asking for the singular knob to go here.
No, it's asking for the stick.
Stick.
I'm not putting anything in.
I promise.
I'm just like, putting it there.
Oh, go and just sit there.
Right, you know what?
I've had enough out of you.
Wait, are these long?
Hold on.
Processing.
Oh, it's upside down.
Wait.
Who said do this?
Dream.
Honestly, I shouldn't freaking go out like that at the beginning.
What's going on?
Hold on.
Can I turn it around for a moment?
Sorry.
Give me a moment, please.
Wait, can Anna just...
Give me a second.
I'm just going to try and test something for a moment.
Is this going to be like...
Hi, is this going to be like 10 times even?
I think I might have just resolved.
Oh, and the microphone's really easy to talk into from here.
Oh, hmm.
Should I have done this from the start?
What?
Me making things more difficult?
Oh, my tracking.
I forgot my tracking.
Okay.
All right, little iPhone, it's your time to shine.
Look, this is how you see me.
Look, it's me.
Hi.
This is how...
Oh, you can see it scanning from my face.
Okay.
Well, anyway, all hail are overlords.
The only problem is it's really hard to read you.
Okay.
Let's go back to what I need to do.
Which is...
Oh, wow.
I can see it a lot easier too.
Who would have thought?
What do you mean if you make this simple for yourself?
It gets easier.
Oh, no.
Okay.
So that does go here.
And then a brown one goes here.
Oh, and the Lego part of the hair.
That went like boom.
Okay.
And then the four by one.
Oh, my gosh, this is going to be so much faster.
Bro, literally name a better duo.
Me making things like 10 times harder than it has to be
and like solving it like an hourly or something.
Don't you love women that are kind of...
Okay.
So that's that strip here, like from here.
I'm just trying to make sure that you can see it in here.
Could I just flip the camera upside down on OBS and spun the book around?
I'm sorry.
I couldn't figure that out.
Okay, long.
Did long.
And then sandstone.
Uh-huh.
Then a four piece.
Sandstone.
And then a long piece.
Oh.
What?
We did it!
Step 21, completo.
Okay, that definitely...
Uh...
I do like making life hard for myself from there.
I'm very overqualified for it.
Right, okay, one brown piece.
Two little browns.
One classic Lego block.
Look, we've got this big Lego set.
Oh.
We can now whisper into your ears how to build it.
Literally.
No, but actually though.
Can you see it?
Like if I was like in your lap, I'm just like,
Hi!
I'm doing my thing.
Okay, so I'm just smurfing.
Literally, I'm real...
I'm trying hard and right.
Let me bring up the pieces so you can see how much is left over.
Like this set is about to be finished.
Look at these pieces.
They're so little.
Okay.
You're looking exceptionally pretty today.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you anonymous for the tip.
I'm glad I could sit on your lap.
Um...
And thank you, Jacazi.
And the Booty Lord.
What's going on?
Hold on.
Why are you all getting the same brain cells?
Sorry.
Going on a date with Momita Legoland Island?
Wait, what?
Is Legoland a place?
I bet you didn't expect to hold some super chat.
Really, I'm sure.
Thank you, the Booty Lord.
Is Legoland a real place?
I did this...
Is it like a video game?
Legoland has a lot of different things.
There's really one point.
Okay, so six by six here.
And then you go there.
And you go...
Yeah.
And there's a little knob of butter.
How did he...
How did he know, like, putting these blocks together
would make something that looks like hoverton?
People must get to that.
What do you say?
That is in Disneyland?
Legoland is in Disneyland.
Oh, it's real?
Ah, can we go to Legoland?
Can we go to Legoland?
Is there anything from Lord of the Rings in Legoland?
Or is it a lie?
And it's just propaganda in the bi-legoland.
Pretend that we care.
But we don't care.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
More sand blocks.
Jeez, wrap it up.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Two uber long sand bars.
Two uber long.
Two medium.
One wee knob of block.
And a two knob of block.
Okay, there we go.
Boom, now what?
All of them?
Okay, so the two long ones go on the outside.
I can do that.
And then those two knob of butter here.
Oh, who goes there?
I'm like a violent child, claiming.
I'm on my high risk one.
I'm late, but hold on.
No, you're not late.
You're not too late.
I really should put ambience on,
just so it's not like me rambling into a room.
You're getting no ambience.
Sorry.
I'll just sing the Hobbit soundtrack, right?
Ready?
We'll do the black gate.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Okay, we did that part.
And then we shall do...
Oh, you never saw that.
You didn't see that, okay?
You didn't see it.
It's all secure.
This isn't going to fall apart.
It's not going to be like a mean world,
like finish it and then it just go apart, okay?
You didn't see it.
Come on.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Well, this better be one, two, three, four, five, six.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
That needs to recalibrate my visual.
I mean, I literally can't see it at all,
so I'm going to just trust that it's doing its thing.
I need to connect these two,
but once they are connected,
I see all the memes about how you'll never unconnect them again.
Ready?
Oh.
For eternity.
Oh, it says turn it around.
Okay.
I think we're putting a chest down.
We'll put a little chest in the middle.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is that a window?
We get to make a window.
Oh, my God.
My nails are in the way of like solidifying it down
because they're like, they're long in front.
Like I would hit that.
I got my nails a little longer.
Okay.
We did that.
Oh, let's fucking blitz through this.
Come on, lads.
Come on.
We're doing it in one stream.
I'm not having this.
What the fuck is that?
Can you even see that?
Bring it down a bit.
Break down there, nail diva.
Can you separate pieces?
They gave me a tool to do it.
I don't actually know how to do it.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, listen to that.
Here's the mark.
Um, right.
I've got me two knobs above.
And I need some sort of weird brick.
Oh.
Did I get to make the fireplace?
Oh, my gosh.
Stop.
What am I making inside of it?
Oh, no.
My nails.
My nail.
Can I even get that in the corner?
Oh, my God.
Legos said they hate me.
Oh, no.
Again, Lay, can I use your paw?
I need to, like, use the tool to get it in the corner.
You just stay right there.
I can't do it.
Oh, my God.
I really hope there's no...
Stop.
I really hope there's not any pieces that are hard like that.
It's, like, right in the corner of it.
Now, I'll use the tool like a hammer.
Okay, we need two long brown sticks and one black, whatever this is.
I guess it's the fireplace.
I would...
If I was a, uh, a losing person, I would totally...
Oops.
And it went away.
I thought this is really...
Who said get nails for this screen, honestly?
I'm a real carpenter.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
I'm going to build a house and...
A shelf?
Oh, no.
No.
Oh, that's wrong.
Get out of here.
You're not supposed to be there.
I'm a Skyrim guard.
You're not supposed to be here.
I...
By order of the hour, I'll stop right there.
You have been...
Okay, I guess I'll let you go then.
Okay, back, back, back, back.
Knock, knock, knock.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, come on, please.
I'm begging.
Oh, that actually...
Okay, I accepted it.
It was accepted.
And now what?
My window ledge is breaking.
I'm being too violent with my current property.
My property.
Okay.
Someone named Johnny said to get nails.
Look, the nails are cute.
Okay, they represent...
I'm doing tons of hand cam streams this week and I was like,
you know what?
It is a fireplace.
Oh my gosh, that's so cute.
Oh, I went away.
It is a fireplace.
Look, these are like little gems.
And then what we do?
A black one.
Put a little bit of butter.
And then the other piece of the fireplace.
Oh, I'm dropping it.
And the other piece of the fireplace.
Okay, for the next one.
Are you kidding me right now?
Come here.
Are you squiddling me right now?
I think that's funny.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank you, baby lord.
I'm glad I can bring back some more memories.
Have I done this wrong?
Oh, you dumba.
My mum used to always be like,
I'm not doing the person who's strong,
because you've been bad.
And then she would always be like, yes.
She's a bit strong and you've been bad.
And I'm like, uh...
Are you squiddling me right now?
No, no, no, please.
I'm reaching 25k.
I'm so proud of you, cologne underscore love.
Oh, thank you.
I've got the 25k.
Oh, I need to order Rebecca's cosplay.
Soon.
Okay, right, you go in the fire.
No, go in it.
Please stay in.
No, don't take it out.
Don't take it out. Leave it in, leave it in.
I don't want it to be taken out yet.
And then we add
to the shelf that is
accumulating on the side.
I don't know what it is.
It's terrible.
Thank you, Nero.
Okay, the shelf is on.
The fire is
falling off.
Please just stay inside there.
It's like, no...
Wait, isn't it?
Oh, wait, no, it is.
It touches to the floor.
Okay, so this is correct.
This mirror right here is correct.
Okay, let me just...
Oh, let me just...
Okay, it's secure.
Oh, my legs are getting sore
because I'm like perching on them.
Your mind of a...
Your mind of a good costume.
Which of the Rebecca?
Rebecca from Cyber
Edge Runners
or Edging Runners
Sorry, I didn't watch that.
For my 30k,
I was going to say that.
25k, Tango.
30k, Rebecca is more...
35k, maybe the
10,000 kisses?
I don't know, maybe 50k.
I don't know.
I was going to do that
fruit stream. Fruit ASMR where I
break it with my legs.
But I need one... No, not that one.
I need one long
two. Yeah. And then two
and a third got to finish the fire plate off.
Okay. I can do that.
I can finish the fire plate off.
Can you see that? I just need to make sure you can
can't see. If you can see it a little bit,
my guilty is done.
Truly, it has nothing else to
accomplish it. We finish the fire plate off.
And then...
we will...
we will finish the...
still.
And then...
I think we're okay.
Did anyone
see anything come flying off it?
That's what I get for being a violent beast
on the stream.
That made my heart drop.
I have worked too hard on this
to break
because of me being like some
ungebunga
caveman coming in and destroying it.
Secure the shell.
It's popped somewhere.
I don't know what made it pop though.
I might just leave it, okay?
If everyone doesn't acknowledge
that it happened, it's gonna be
fame.
I just realized you can't even see it.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh!
It has a safety...
The fire poker has a safety thing.
Oh, what is it called?
The fire guard. That's it.
It's literally a guard to fire for any sparks
because if your wood has a lot of oxygen
in it, then it will
like go peep peep peep peep peep peep.
And you see? Where is the other green one?
I have one green one.
Oh, there's only one green one.
Oh my gosh!
That's actually adorable.
Sorry. I want to live in my Lego
Hobbit tent. That is so cute!
Look at the fire!
We can have soup and stuff!
I'll pretend I know
how to make bread in a pot.
I know you can make bread in a pot. I don't know how
but I know you can do it.
Look, I've seen someone do it before so obviously
it's real and true, okay? It's real and true.
Bread.
We need to
put sandstone on top of the fireplace
to complete it.
Oh my gosh!
It's so cute!
And then we need a fort.
I don't know. Oh, you didn't see that?
I literally went, oh my god!
It's so cute!
And like squished.
That is almost wrong.
Right.
I need a
three piece.
Do I have a brown three piece?
Hello, I was like one brown
three piece. I don't know.
I don't seem to have this
available.
Where is the piece I need?
Oh my god, I've actually lost it.
No, I don't want it.
Am I sitting on it?
It says
one, two, three.
Hmm.
Ah.
Where is it?
Is it in my book?
No, it's in my book.
A three piece brown.
I don't see a three piece.
Three piece brown.
I don't see four. Are you sure that's three?
It is.
Hello.
Is it an important thing?
Check this out.
Hmm.
Hello.
Has that actually lost it?
I don't think so.
Ripped green things.
Oh, you're right. Sorry. Sorry.
I don't want to do it.
Is it possible to say it's missing a piece?
Does that happen often?
She knows.
Yeah, I'm reading chat.
I know I'm trying to multitask and do two things at once.
But I am reading.
I don't know where this random.
Are you squinting me right now?
I haven't lost any pieces.
Whoa.
Is that kind of an extra card?
Yeah.
Thank you, Jean.
I don't know if I would do more.
Green pieces back home.
Yes, it is.
But where's the brown thing?
I was like, one brown thing?
Where is it?
I don't think it's here.
Genuinely, I've not lost any piece yet.
What did I do if they never put it in the freaking thing?
Literally.
Is it asking for a brown thing?
Can I continue without it?
Right, we're going to have to brute-freaken-
Don't know if it will help,
but maybe you can use the scammed setbox
as a solid base to build on.
Oh, I'm not sure.
I think I'll get very confused if I open up.
Right, I'm going to see if I can build without it.
I know that sounds really silly,
but...
I'm making...
Fuck.
It would essentially be hovering
if I were to
continue for...
Thank you, Sophie for that.
Lift up your entire Lego set.
It's not in the bag.
I don't think it came.
I've literally not lost any piece.
And this is like a...
thing that I'm...
Oh, I'm going to fart.
I'm so angry.
Nothing's on the floor.
Those are the other pieces.
There's nothing room in the box.
And there's nothing.
Right here.
I'm looking
for a brown
three piece,
and it's genuinely not here.
Like if I separate
the green and the brown,
it's not
actually here.
I'm not looking on it.
And this is the box.
Wait, am I...? No.
Don't be silly.
Stop it. I'm giving myself hope.
Go for a walk,
and if you feel
pieces on your feet...
For the next bag,
put all pieces in a bowl
so that you don't lose them.
I think we might have to...
Oh, sorry. Hold on.
I'm just stretching.
That feels nice to stand up.
Thank you, Master.
Are you squidding me right now?
It might be underneath the stuff we already built.
Normally, there's nothing.
Okay, I'm going to continue.
We must persevere.
We can't be...
That was Sauron's doing.
Clearly.
Sauron's absolutely shagging us right now.
He's...
Whoa, that just appeared.
This is all Sauron's doing.
This is all Sauron's work.
He's manipulating us.
Okay, can you see that?
I think so.
Right, we're going to build the fireplace
without the...
The lesson here is I buy too many Legos.
Also,
current favorite sets are Optimus Prime
and Bumblebee.
Hope they do a Decepticon next.
Have you done a Decepticon Bumblebee?
I don't know Bumblebee how to sing with you.
Thank you, James, for the tip again.
What are you, a Lego nerd?
A Lego nerd?
I too identify with a Lego nerd.
Okay, so we don't have
this little three piece that the shelf
is about to sit on.
However, we can attach the underneath
of the shelf to hide the fact
that we don't have that piece.
So I think
in terms of any piece that could
have gone missing...
Are you squidding me right now?
We're doing alright.
What?
That's not how it works.
If this story is like, this is a story of good and evil.
You don't go, yes,
this is the evil person has a point.
No.
Stop it, Bumblebee.
Nice nails, thank you.
I can't wait for you to see
why they're like this.
Right.
A little bit of the shelf is now off.
Okay, tricky.
But we'll do it.
Don't worry.
So the shelf goes...
not like that.
It does go like that.
So in theory,
if the shelf was correct,
the piece would go like this.
This is
not gonna work the way I would like it to,
but that's okay.
Because that is the way. He overcomes
the annoying stuff.
I said
you overcome
the annoying stuff there.
So now we have a levitain shelf.
Bumble, fix that shelf right now.
Okay, that's fine.
I accept my fate.
The reason why I said that,
I'm like 99% sure
that song, Jewel of the Fate,
is that.
Thank you. I'll be here a week.
I'm sorry.
I haven't got a brain right now.
Okay, we're just extending the shelf
further in this corner.
Sorry, I'm doing a really bad job of making sure
you can see what I'm doing.
These streams are like really,
really hot.
It's just so difficult.
I don't want to make it
easier for you.
Don't just wish you,
don't just do it, do it.
I need to support this now.
We'll put a new thing on.
The knob of butter.
It's stuck in my head now.
So I hope you enjoy that Star Wars
and your fantasy.
Right, and then do the shelf again.
Right, I can do the shelf again and have that.
This side is supported,
so I don't need to do like two.
Ah, I can't put pressure on it.
Whereas this side, I literally have to
finger to make sure
it's supported.
There, we have
a beautiful
shelf.
I mean, it's not that obvious.
Hold on. It's really not
that obvious that the bottom piece is on there.
Oh my
girl, I love Hobbit 2.
I love Hobbit 2.
We should fuck
unprotected. Sorry.
That's my insight though.
Don't listen to me.
I'm doing something I'm doing right now.
I'm having a good time.
Don't listen to a thing that comes
out of my mouth.
We need grass verges.
Will someone please think of the grass verges?
No.
You're in my head.
You've done it.
No.
No more
missing pieces.
Soon, mommy, just a couple of days
I enjoy when you have no fellow
agree, but seeing all those
pieces not cut to properly that
11.
We won't miss it.
Are you squiddling me right now?
In my white balance.
Maybe your Lego piece fell in or under your clothes.
Maybe ditch them for a bit
and shake them so it falls out.
No other or bad intentions
off course.
Honestly, real and
wait, maybe it could be like this.
And before it is up Leslie, that would be hilarious.
I'm just like, hocus pocus and it appears.
I honestly
wouldn't put it behind me that it's like
somehow attached itself on my butt when I
slam down on front.
I'm going to check my pocket.
Right, okay, turn it around.
You're now going to add the grass to
hop up it in.
Outside the window, there's a big
old piece right here.
Then at this
corner is a big old piece right here.
Right here.
And then there's a wee piece right here.
There you go.
Right to that end.
And put that down there.
And then put that one there.
I'm going to have to hammer this in because
because it's against like a brick wall,
literally a Lego brick wall, it hurts too much
to put my wee fingernails to work.
So I'm
going to go
home
to the other day.
Did I say thank you?
No, thank you.
No.
Thank you.
I'm going to take it out of here.
Right.
We've not even finished part one of this.
How long am I in?
I'm an hour 30, are you joking?
Surely it gets
easier than this, right?
Surely.
Surely this isn't going to
accidentally be a several string, right?
I thought this was going to be quick.
I didn't realize how big it was.
That's the size of my hand.
Okay, so that's the grass marriage done.
And then
let's move it a little bit to the side.
We need
one long
two long, two slopes.
Two slopes.
Okay, I'm getting pranked.
Okay.
That's now another brown missing piece.
That kind of
kind of
missing piece.
Wait.
That's like major pieces
missing.
Oh, Don.
I'm laughing.
That's more
pieces like tall for the missing.
These are
two long ones.
It's asking for a wee one.
But I don't have a wee one.
The only wee one
they're under the window.
They're under the window.
Maybe they're in another bag.
This is set one though.
Like I assume it's going to tell me
to, yeah, open up.
Wow.
Okay.
It's asking me
to set up the window.
Which I can.
Yeah, these are wrong. Look.
Okay. I know this looks silly.
It's asking for two wee pieces
and it's giving me two brown pieces
that aren't wee. These are massive.
These aren't for the window.
And it's not asking for these two pieces
anywhere else. The practice
wrong.
Is that Legos? It must be Legos fault
the practice wrong.
I can't even complete the second window.
You know,
like one of the major structure points.
I'm not being
funny, Legos. You're going to fucking charge that
much. You're going to fucking pack
that shit correctly. Is that
for real?
How are
like it's asking for
I don't know what to do.
I can't complete the window.
I mean, I can do this.
I need to
I need one of the main structures
that are doing something on the side.
I can't complete the
window.
I'm just going to fucking kill myself.
No, maybe there's
another multiple bad member. No.
This is how this
comes.
One.
And then
we're about to do the front of
Bag Ends, which is two.
One point on.
Some pieces look the same.
So you may have used wrong once when
building. Check to see if there are any
that aren't supposed to be there on the
bill.
I don't think I can do
so myself.
You know when you want
something to go right?
That fucking goes wrong.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do a pepper.
Shoot up a fucking
Walmart.
What?
That's really going to bother me.
Why would you do that to me?
Why would you fucking the most autistic
person?
Right, okay.
Forget the window.
Forget the windy. Forget the
windy.
Oh, just ripped the page.
Oh my god, that's...
Streamer gets so angry, destroys her
property live on stream.
I just ripped that.
Can you see that?
Oh my god.
Streamer so angry, breaks her own
property. I can't believe it.
Oh my god, what a violent beast.
What a violent fucking beast.
I was like, I missed this tip.
Hold on once again.
Stash power. Some people won't be
saying you may have used the wrong ones
when building. Check to see if there aren't
any that aren't...
No, the window one's correct.
Who? Oh, that's Matt.
What are you doing?
Thank you Stash Power and the MNNC
officers.
What a good ad campaign
if I saw one of them.
Streamer anymore.
Where's the...
Right, okay. Letters
analize what we've done so far.
We're going back
to the fucking
bastard
book to look for these
these.
Okay.
This fucking bastard.
Oh, so I'm not trying to wait any longer.
If I find out that
I've done something wrong, at least
that's human error.
Oh.
Hold on a minute.
Now, hold on.
Don't laugh.
Stop it.
Stop laughing at me.
No.
I can see it taking.
Give me that back to the bastard.
Give me these fucking
fanies back.
Oh.
Give me them.
He's mine.
What does this tool even
accomplish?
How do you get it out?
Give me my fucking
pieces.
Give me my pieces.
No, I'm going to break it.
Break the whole board.
Are you squidding me right now?
I see them. It's those ones.
Thank you.
I'm crying.
I can't eat.
What do you do?
What were you made for?
Is this not what your purpose is?
What is your purpose?
To unscoop Lego.
Oh my god.
Unscoop the Lego.
I don't...
How do I take it out?
Sorry. What is your purpose?
Do you like bring it with me?
Do I like attach you like this?
No.
Fuck off.
Give me the Lego pieces.
I can't progress.
I can't grab it.
They're clearly not what it's intended for.
Even though it may visually replace it.
I can't make it visually replace it.
What is that?
I'm gonna end up breaking the pull down.
It doesn't hold it in.
Are you squidding me right now?
Right. You know what?
You were using it right on the side.
Just need the right angle.
Brian is having a stroke.
One.
Okay.
Put it back together again.
What's this trick?
It's a leg.
A leg.
Sorry.
I just sounded like the transformer sound there.
Right.
Where's that piece?
There.
Okay. No more.
No more.
Then put the leg on it.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Oh my god. I'm happy again.
I'm not upset anymore.
I'm not mad at the world.
Be safe.
You have broken the curse.
I am not happy.
So what's that?
Put one there.
Uh-huh.
And then stand the platform.
Okay.
Because you are my witness.
As you are my witness.
You are my witness.
Witness man.
That's the movie.
It's called Mad Max.
Max is so mad.
He mad it all the way up and down.
Right.
We need two greens.
We're going straight back into it.
I promise I'm not mad.
Mommy's not going to hurt you.
Okay.
I'm not going to hurt you.
I promise.
Okay.
So we need two slopes.
We need four mini slopes.
We need like tiny little guys.
We do.
Uh-huh.
And then one big slope.
Yeah. And then what are we doing?
Put one next to the window.
Put one there.
Put three.
One.
No.
Oh god.
Get the tool out.
Right.
One there.
One facing outwards at the
door.
Open the door.
There's going to be a door.
Close but no cigar.
More like a cigarette.
But don't say a British cigarette
or you'll be bad.
I don't even love cultural difference.
Mommy's in the other room so
thank you.
The cost is
$65.
And a tip for you.
Which really wasn't much of a tip actually.
To the tip more.
If I didn't
because I was moving
out of it.
I think I'm going to have to wait.
I think I'm going to have to wash my hands.
I don't want to get sick.
I get so worried about getting sick.
I don't want to.
Okay.
Hold on.
I just skipped the.
No.
Don't start falling apart.
I will cry.
Don't do this to me now.
I'm too emotionally vulnerable.
After what just happened.
After those.
Okay.
Grass.
It goes next to the tall one.
Okay.
Oh, you're next.
Thank you for showing up.
You're actually next.
You're my next time.
I cry.
All right.
Bye.
I'm at the end of that time.
Sorry.
I'm losing it a little bit.
I didn't think this was going to take as long as it did.
I'm going to be honest.
I'm recording short.
An ed and a collab.
If I could do that.
Okay.
And then we're jumping to this stage here.
I'm not going to have to come back here.
Can I go get a cola?
Are you winning?
I'm getting my ass beat by little pieces of plastic.
Microplastic.
More like fucking macro plastic.
My ass is getting fucking beat.
I'm off to get a cola.
I'm getting a cola.
Okay.
Got a cola.
Oh, fucking.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look at how girthy it is.
My god, what a girthy can.
Let's see.
That was my hand wrapped around that can.
Had an injury.
Anyway.
Let me get back in position.
Okay, done the grass verges.
Sorry, the schizophrenia is coming down now.
I'm not as angry.
Mommy's up.
Okay.
Two long ones and a skinny long one.
Two long ones at the side of the window.
To the wall.
To the sweat drop of my bowl.
Of sweet sweet molester.
Of sweet sweet got down.
Sweet sweet got down.
Sorry, I'm trying not to make this like
the longest fucking Lego building stream
on a man right.
Move it that way.
And what would moving it this way do?
Give me access to this window.
And it's asking for a platform.
Oh my god.
Do platform it right now.
What does it do?
Just platform it right now.
Okay, so we have like a window.
Are you squinting right now?
I did a little backflip.
Mama, I have seen too much corn concerning canons
and human orifices.
Thank you, Dan.
Sorry, this is a man.
I'm a man.
Mommy, I've seen too much corn concerning canons
and human orifices.
I always wanted to fit a can up there.
So...
So does it.
Step two.
Okay.
We did one stage of four.
That was incredibly hard.
So we have left over pieces
of this randomly.
So yeah, I guess
what, can you mess with Lego
and be like, hey, you actually didn't give me this piece
and they'll be like, sure, we'll ship it out.
Even if it was like a set that was snake ages ago.
Can someone,
if I open a peel box,
can someone send me brown three by one?
I just need brown three by one.
That's all.
I don't ask for much as a streamer,
but if I open a peel box,
that was my ankle cracking if you heard that
before someone's like, hey.
Oh my god.
Are you squid me right now?
I don't know, are you squid me right now?
I agree with my fellow leaflings.
Use the Lego too?
Oh my gosh, are you ready?
No way.
Oh, come on.
Well, that was a
cause I can do this, but
there we go.
Thank you.
Would you like first drink?
It's all yours.
Make sure your
your hydra is
oh my god we did part one and now we need yet to do three more parts of how
painful that experience was right windows together what I mean that's me
finished this booklet
your mommy right I'm gonna go get a bowl oh wait why would I need to get a bowl
if I have this right here right as you're my witness and before you're like
scrawny where's your bowl is right here okay I have a ball too you want to see
it hold on let me open it I need to stand up to give my legs a rest and I can
reach out very easily from here
yes I'm converting no no I don't care
I'm I'm not cool okay let's get number two
let me get your pupper tea right as you are my witness and 720p because
this webcam's piece of shite and not for key I'm gonna open it and I'm gonna pour
it into your bowl right close enough close enough right this bag is empty
correct everyone agrees the bag is empty this is what fell out I'm putting
it in right now I'm putting it in okay and then we have two we bags which we're
not gonna open up just yet but as you are my witness all here baby okay we
require sand three times one okay yummy no please don't eat that right sand three
times one and two things I'm gonna put these bags a little to the right not a
little to the left I am now going to see these are big pieces right okay new
plan right we're putting the weird right these are very big pieces like these
are the windows in the door okay so I'm gonna leave these here okay leave these
in here and then strongy here is gonna have the two bags inside that have the
weird pieces alright as you are my witness all the pieces are going in as
you are my witness empty empty we have big bowl we both and whoever said your
special interest can't get you far okay big bowl we both big brown circles are
mine I'm alert for a bit don't worry
you like shown he's doing a magic trick focus okay right it's asking not for
that it's asking for a bit but asking for four four one by three which is in this
bowl nope that's a full circle and one two okay third one oh my god some sword
is oh it's staying it's staying oh my gosh it's staying this is Bilbo sword it
glows up when orcs are nearby oh my god oh wait no it's the party invite
what what the what's the timeline if the hobbits are showing up it's not sorry wait
this must be the contract that has to be because it's hobbit this isn't the other
one right a four by three fan here is okay so that's four three by one fan and
then asking for two big chunky blocks which isn't in this one so goodbye
strongy there you are I need one and then I need a second okay this method the
dog bowl method it's so much easier I said what I said I said what I said I'm
glad you're in the sink glad you're willing to explore kinks with me cuz
this is working out sometimes okay okay and then we'll put them to the side and
we'll go back to building all right put the two sands together like that is this
light is the light from the ring light to glaring there is that better or do you
want your blending I don't know it's easier for you I'll leave it I'll leave
this I'll set the mid-light and with this orange kind of glow okay we're clipping
together the single threes to make a three by two no three by one okay at the
doors so add the blocks add the triangular blocks facing the doorway
oh definitely blinding the yellow is to yellow it's very bright I'll turn it down
more
all right doesn't go any more sorry my knees and the way okay this doesn't help
it's just the light in the room sorry sorry it's got streamed I promise I'll
get better at hand yeah and then they're like a half height close it like a
sign which that page done nope why do you keep flying please relax why what are
you struggling oh maybe this oh hold on it's gently now isn't when I okay that's
better yeah I'll do I'll do donkey I'll do I don't have some good problem is just the
reflection on the book shining everywhere stop it mr. book you're ruining it you're ruining
the you're moving in the room in the knee okay right step two of part two
and right we both we need mom is looking like one of those untrustworthy anime characters who
have their eyes always closed Brock is the only exception to this doesn't brock open his eyes
thank you the beauty lord thank you anonymous sorry I just reread anonymous's thing next time you do
this close the cavern entrance so no pieces get lost in spelunk bro yeah it is right
right right one can you see that you can okay one
three and any two of these pieces okay and instructions they put the brown one on the tan
one okay oh no it doesn't just put it sideways like that and then it says take the blonde one
and put it the opposite direction fucking hello please please close I do not have the
the strength of the good lord who's got the strength to build Legos I need I need those sets
that are like a hundred pieces and no more okay so this is outside the door at back end
nope wrong way open the door here we go good girl here's a good boy
and then we take a blonde with a hole and then a blonde
with a hole and then two tan that's in the weeble
I swear if this is the wrong color of tan no it's the right one
I'm just gonna check there's not like some other insidious looking one
um a blonde with a hole
okay wait what this is not the correct piece over that one
okay so one with a hole pointing one way that's fine
and then a blonde piece with a wee knob coming out of it but it's not that it's like a full cube
a full cube with a knob
what
I'm enolizing normal cube cube with a hole cube like this looks like it but it's not
nah then you start doing this to me
is it you you've got a hole in me wait no it's the exact thing
is it in here refling are you hiding this piece from me and hopes that I get mad and are we're due
are you no these are like such big pieces
what am I looking at enolize hold on pause the tunes
what the fuck
what is that
what is this
what the fuck is that
the body pieces are there
there's only one piece at the hole
I'm sorry I'm looking I'm scanning with my eyes
oh is it you oh I found it okay I just took me a bit longer than you
right okay the hole goes one way the pole goes the other surprise
and then talk to us this gorgeous lovely I said close it
me
okay and then we
oh that's not how have I done that
oh no
I've put it on the wrong side
what oh no wait wait wait
um when you're missing something that she's going to take us somewhere
oh my god wait that was so easy oh my god this cool this tool is cool it's so cool
I'm sorry um
it takes me a minute to get something out of my English hard
okay so that way and then that one facing this way gorgeous stunning and then take this bit
and then put them together like a sandwich that was so much easier than
why is this they're not like straight
you know
I'm trying to make it
surely there's nothing there we go
the most basic pieces take me the hardest and longest time
that's the front of bag and right now it's good I think
okay we stuff first
I have one grass look two grass look one cube of green which is in your bowl
thank you for holding on to it for me wherever it is a green
and then two we sandstone complete sandstone
sandstone okay see it's always that we really win kids that are the harder
let me check that you can still see what I see okay a little bit further a little bit further
but not too much yeah right the cube
the cube goes here
yeah that's fine but where does this that go oh I see it at the outskirts of the door at back end
and then what do these two grass verges do
one two three four one two three four
four and then assume over here
there's a missing grass there
oh okay grass marriage cube
and these two
okay small wheelie thank you though I think that looks very correct I'm going to take a hydration
of my cola before it gets flat you do not drink flat colas around these parts I'm sure
mommy prefers some small things but I'm not having a delivery I'm still waiting
but I think bear bagging makes them like custom so uh two block cube
hmm I think it's in your one okay these blocks are in your one
me okay yeah one of those would you like some of this on your that
I'm going to get some for you Amy was talking about licking flat diet drink like flat fizzy juice
I know I'm sorry but I'm gonna have to do what needs to be done I know I said suspensions
are a thing at viola but I'm sorry Amy it's just the way it has to be
your first this suspension we are concerned about Amy's screen time we're going to she is now
resting we're so concerned we're so concerned we're that you're hiding it very well from me
come on up is that it there no where is it it's a two block of sandstone
and I am pranked by you right now there is both put the door back in or else I'm going to forget
I forgot okay two bits of sandstone lemon candy oh sorry who's that
I'm sorry I don't know what I'm on about I think I'm starting to lose it a little bit
I didn't know again much before I did not get a high quality of sleep because I had to go
I had to be a big girl and take my be a blocker so I wouldn't have been a partner
okay right we've done that step and the next step is grass verges it's always grass verges
um one one of these how big is it 40 um and then a skinny okay we had them had the jackpot
how long did you sleep I think maybe
six hours but you know when you wake up and you're like that was not a quality sleep like
that was absolutely shy so I was like one of them he's like a Christmas tree okay wait what
whoa hold on a minute don't be silly don't be silly wrap your willy today so you don't have to
support because she'll be going to court to get every time she can get to you so don't be like
everyone so that we're gonna watch the scheme soon all right if you're really impatient you
can type in the scheme on xbox not on the scheme on twitter no on youtube pick a platform on youtube
right I need four window frames oh please pick it up oh no okay I got it I was gonna say it's
like one of them awkward materials that nails can't pick up I always forget when I don't have
nails anymore that I literally am useless oh I have two stings oh my gosh look it's even bigger
there all right I need window tracels or whatever they're called I need window frames window frames
the only time I know I slept well I was gonna draw on my pillow honestly I can tell if like
I had a good sleep over it was just absolute gremlin do you want gremlin do you want some
any comments I knew I heard you bumped about it oh surprise surprise I open the door for you
as if I don't open it every time you come out screaming on the other side of it come say hi to
the refunds okay no it's not what it looks like gremlin I promise I don't have fetish balls
right now what are you talking about you don't come over and sell it
who is this last window frame I'm not staring at it
oh there it is you just left are you not even coming to say hi to the refunds gremlin
gremlin gremlin you little shit come over here you're letting all the heat out of the room gremlin
come here I got you she's entered the room again come here does it look different
does the room look different
come here come right here wait where can the refund see it come smell my lego that's
a really bizarre thing come smell my lego right now right now you're letting all the heat out of
the room either come over to me or not surprise surprise I'm not dead in this room I don't know
why she always does this she's like someone's dying
give me cool ones then I'm gonna finish this thing and put it on
just give me cool ones that you think that they're doing to clean this thing around the door
you're gonna show yourself off and you're gonna be like your mom and be like you're
hurt on camera all right that's what I thought get the fuck out of here
I love my weed in there
it says shelf the frame of the windows just end here
oh wow oh I like perfectly fit perfect
oh I'm so sorry if you can hear gremlin
it's not time to go in and guard me either because there is a bird in it
are these yeah it's only supposed to be like a little bit
gremlin's like us when she doesn't see mommy
yeah come on
oh
I just want to be in stress and some some days she actually genuinely couldn't give
less of a shit if I was alive or not and then other days she's like oh my god
Stranny where have you been are you good me right now are you
what are you saying little todo cosmosus cosmosus as in osmosis thank you for the membership I hope
you enjoyed them oops aren't cats normally like that literally damn girl you got really pretty
oh thank you because i got my nails glued it looks like right foot window one two three four
you know those three gaps that are left like here and here and here and here yeah those are windows
oh don't do what I just did oh wait hold on oh
oh
wait wait is listen
bend over and spell run are you in
wait no wrong wrong location
sorry I'm like I'm doing this is it's hard to like talk and think at the same time
I'm surprised how much I enjoyed building Legos though I saw that she did a
Gunpla no it's not called Gunpla Gunpla Gunpla okay my brain's saying Gunpla
you plan she did a building thing of the Japanese robot gun Gundam style nope that's a
fucking location in Japan no it's not Gundam style is a fucking thing in Korea I'm sorry
um oh it is Gunpla oh my gosh maybe I am a real weird
right it's asking for four arches like this so I'm gonna say you have them because these are big
it's totally not because I watch all those like Japanese creators that talk about life in
Japan and they're like they talk about all the good of it oh my god I have a broom oh my god
I already know my job in Hobbiton um I watch like those ones that are talk about like life in
Japan and they're like as nice as it is like Japan's like apparently um a wee bit racist or
something like that and I'm like honestly I'm still going for the chicken like even if they
didn't like Scottish folk I think I'll survive like honestly my ego is gonna survive I just want
sorry I think I'm gonna go and make sure I might need to open the door again
um
eight little knobs of these oh I need eight um like I I wasn't kidding if you didn't catch the
Katarina collab um I had a a talking collab with Wee Katarina um she was talking about like what
would you like to do on vacation I was like I enjoy watching like those Japanese vloggers
sorry um I was I like watching those Japanese vloggers that are like oh I um
English
I just want to try the food like uh no they don't no like they're not like hateful or
absolutely not no it's not hateful it's literally just like and I'm like honestly
I get it like I heard like the police can be detainee and all that and stuff like that
but I would just I just want to try Family Mart chicken and then the um what other that other
one as well the the convenience they're called convenience stores called a convene and I would
figure it out one day I was um and how the friend is actually well if he can't eye me
she's actually independent now um but yeah I like watching what is it there's this place
that does beef bowl and just a bit yackadon no wait is that that popcorn terminology you told me
it's like a beef bowl it's literally like cheese rice and beef and I'm like that's exactly
like the kind of food I focus in like the food's bland in Japan and that and I'm like
to me it's actually like the best kind of food because like you didn't need like a
billion different flavorings and seasonings and all that like if you do it you know your stuff then
oh sorry I just realized you can't even fucking see anything I'm doing right now I am so sorry I'm
wait oh my god sorry
um what where do you go
it goes under the pool right but by one
whatever is you're doing stop it sorry I need to press them like strategically
I need to press them on it or somewhere
uh I hope it's not bland no it's not bland it's like you got like the perfect
like it's not overwhelming stuff like that I'm putting the fashion touches on the windows
oh whoa whoa the whole bit of fucking garden just came off as well how did I not notice this
me like oh yeah not always good no it does not look good but not like
I'm definitely not doing something right but the good news is I'm having fun
so even if this goes horrifically wrong I'm having a good time and I'm glad to get to spend it
together I like doing something a bit different as well like this feels different from like
sitting down and plop plop plopping on a video game
mummies we think you are unable to apply enough pressure I'm I'm very weak unfortunately my
grand I think it's like whoa wait hold on
nothing there ah right this is literally the piece that I'm supposed to do first
use your brain where is it where's your brain come on stop
you run
say this line where is your brain right that's it user send me content so I can just
content one I've had enough I've had enough all right that was the one sansone two brown
this thoughtful method is so fucking superior though I don't care
right one two three four five six and then one long green one skinny green
are you hydrating me Flynn am I going to have to fart in your mouth
oh my god it's been another hour are you joking god I can yet
how does Deldo Baggins do it don't you call him that he did not go through hell on earth for
that he's a good man mummy says she has peasant genes but I think she would be a terrible fan
oh no I'm the peasant that like cleans the halls and serves like I mean I've already
been a waitress and I can manage the waitress and so I think I'm just destined to be a waitress like
I'm gonna work at a cafe
or I might get a job at my boss lady's shop and she's always nice to me but you hide him
and she'd be like what the fuck do you want to hide me
okay we add the sandstone and then the one green here what an interesting
thing and then one wee piece though and one long piece
one skinny long piece
skinny long piece
and then is that gonna be in my dog's bowl
no it's in my dog's bowl okay
is it it is
curious can you hear on your phone where does it go
oh it goes in the corner right
yeah
yeah if we ever do this again I'm probably going to do those like you know those pokemon
ones that have like a hundred pieces and no more yeah that's probably much more in my speed
this is advanced I don't care what anyone says this is hard
and strongy what do you mean it's hard all you're doing is putting these pieces right you know what
in life you will meet a variety of people some people enjoy a nice calm experience
where they don't have to think okay it's the best pleasure in life where you don't have to think
for yourself okay I said what I said and I made it I want to be dumb I want to be collared
hmm fuck ass naked
sorry I'm I'm actually losing it I'm genuinely losing it a little bit
I think it's because I can't read you either it's making like I'm having to look around
but what is the age group of this activity too damn low because this is in life there's real
work everyone is bad at something it's nice to see it coming together it is I do agree the birds
are chirping I severely underestimated how long this was gonna take and because my dummy dumb dumb
ass was like haha I will get so much work done after the stream I think my brain's like what are you
doing
right one grass courage got it and what the rest are in here oh they are two little fans
and then one week bit where it is there is
I love this old moment so please why are you being so mean
you're okay that's a m&m song
it's like levity but why why are you levity oh sometimes the simplest solution is also the easiest
and sometimes in life the easiest solution is a shift
it's like putting a bandage over a gash
whoa
oh it's literally just goes on the window thank goodness thank goodness my window's coming together
cute cut off fingers yeah you like mom's fingers look oh my god
it's so cool are you mean I already done this page okay I'm kind of blasting through it I think
maybe the problem with time is just like having to rake around for the objects like so hard
versus this method that we're doing right now is pretty pretty okay that's a flat square I need
I need a lean grass verge any grass verge appreciators any appreciators a good grass
I mean what the f**k am I doing
well that one definitely goes there
and then there's a wee off piece here right okay
uh right I need to hammer it then oh the freak it down oh did you see that
it's paint back into the bowl
you don't want to go in
why not go in but then where does this one go it says I need to two
two
hold on well look at the schematics
oh I'm raising this one here
okay but that still doesn't explain where this one goes this is here
oh that doesn't explain us
it's not in oh I see it I see it I see it I see it I see it I see it I see snow paws
you need my one patreon upload when oh yeah if you're a bleeding heart a reefland or a snow
barrier there's a new patreon audio I now no longer deal with the patreon audio
so you're a problem now that's right you have to edit the girls audios and then listen to it
yes we okay what do I need I need six barrels
you listen to it was my my punk my bobertons off you can't talk about that
whoa I can't see that do you think you would like make the colors a bit easier I must be
the light in my room honestly okay right three in a row up the window three in a row up the window
and I must remember that you should be able to see it
three in a row up the room up the room up the room up the room up the room up the room
whoa
I can't I'm telling feathers okay we're blasting
doing
and then I need two wee greenians just the one more for ones and flat
I too am somewhat familiar with the concept of flat
okay and I'm gonna put it on the end
oh my freaking crack a larkin trying to get this piece in
it's like go okay then and then put this up oh my gosh it's all coming together
oh my god oh my god
just say cute in french you say
yes I just did sth in french what you're gonna do about it huh you're gonna twerk
yes for these
I called you
I'm gonna shoot what if I want to do both
and one more how do you even attach the door that that's a concept my small mind can
oh I found it I found it I found it I found it
like we're rummaging e-smart right let's get right into whatever that is this thing
okay one do that two do this and then three
like that
but there's a burn piece as well
hold on this requires and hi IQ what am I looking at
is it a flat burn bit at once no this has got a slope on it
although in productions to a halt production is to a halt it's a standstill what
it looks like an arrow point
is it on the outside is my question hold on hold on hold on enolize
it would go like so that's step two the whole piece is there that piece is like ready to
oh no it's not oh it is and then it's like that like it just sits on it for some texture
that's where my money's going right now
that's where my money's going right now oh oh I see it now I see it now it's 3d it's 3d
thinking 3d love thinking three dimensions thinking three dimensions
they're pointing downwards let me so much more sense than what I was thinking
what are you thinking about oh we did it we did it we just have to
no I can't laugh yet okay that looks much better than originally why are you
doing
you know what can wet okay turn it a little bit and then do it now for the piece that goes that way
so flip it in your brain right and then do that right and then it's like this right yes and then
do it like that okay oh we fucking nailed it this is for nine year olds by the way
you just thought you should know that I just you know that small detail that this is for nine
year olds yeah I don't know what freaking super genius nine year olds would be built in this
way they say but bruv bruv this is not easy okay no add that thing and add to that one
okay okay all right all right you did it boom I'm just checking that's right
okay and then we go to the next step thank god it's something easy I just need two brown
chocolate barrette oh no go back in the ball what I need one two three I need a six two six by two
how's that how's that I am to turn it around
make sure you can see and to turn it around and I am to place the brown on top
please don't gain any IQ you're perfect you are oh yeah it's all coming together she doesn't want to
know what kind of difficult legos you were doing I don't know I'm very I'm very how everyone knows
so I'm to
I have
hold on
ah okay not a big deal it was just these
it was it was the door was not that tall this is for hobbits okay it the door is not that
tall it is not necessary for it to be that tall that makes a lot more sense I was panicking I was
like ah I've completely messed it up again what are the odds oh shocking okay fine next one by four
sand I have that okay I know this is for the doorway but what is the best part of Scotland
and the food and I apologise in advance for if the question sounded serious
huh but what is the best part of Scotland and the food best part Glasgow near either
and um food fish and chips I miss I miss Scottish fish and chips and they'll go yeah you want
salt and salt and you say yeah you want brown sauce in the corner and uh brown sauce in the
corner with salt uh all over um I can't think of any other takeaway oh my god I get to oh my god
the fireplace has detail oh my god it has a frying pan oh my god I never even saw that oh my god I'm a
chef I'm actually a chef because I'm cooking right we'll make the fireplace and thank you for the tip
uh typical nation Billy's mega chippy the fact you even know that's where
right what I'm about to take out I'm to take out the contract I'm to take out
a frying pan did I take it out no I put it back in cheeky and the oh oh okay it's cheeky frying
and then a bottle it looks like a bottle with something inside it for a prop but I don't
another thing they haven't included
potentially I'll know I'll know by then right okay connect one piece onto the other
on top of them add the two hook pieces okay
I don't have the strength for this like um surely there's a simpler way like surely
there's a simpler way than breaking my I can't oh and Gimli stop nothing Gimli if I open that door
you're actually gonna come in and say this time are you just gonna stare at me in amazement of what
I'm doing when they're still moving and then what another one on top okay right I can do that
and then what put the wait why is it asking for the no
oh it's telling me to place the items around wait maybe the
not that I can see okay I think we've just forgotten it right the chimney shaft
who went up the ventilation shaft oh my god is that a Star Wars present
yeah
it shows the top of that but
Ah! Because these are wrong, that's why. One second, don't panic! Why do you always panic?
Just because I completely messed it up one time, didn't mean to do it again. I was like,
why is the top of the furnace exposed when I can't see it? Right, frying pan, furnace.
Um, the note in the bottle on the shelf over here, one in. That's the letter.
It used to be addressed to Bill Bowie with a little contract.
He's been stirring the thorn open shield and comforting and coal and coals.
Okay, hydration check. Gallaudet's famous for its seasonal depression, that last one.
Oh, okay. You're not wrong. You're not wrong because of the lack of sunlight.
I think about over, like, 50% of the UK-like experience is depression.
Uh, no, not chicken tikka masala. Scots do love a good curry.
We love Indians because they have delicious food and they bring it and it's delicious.
Um, right, I don't have the bottle. It's asking for the broomstick, right?
Whereas that was in your one. Give me the broomstick.
There is broomstick and then a cup and then two pillars, which I do have right here.
Oh, pardon. And then a cup.
Right, we're putting the cup on the stove, I guess.
Well, if it was all cast iron, or however we call it, it would 100%.
And then we're putting the broom away.
Oh, please don't break it.
Right, okay, broom's away.
And then we're ploughing down the wheat fellers.
Oh my God, it's all coming together.
Yes, that's that one. Yeah, unfortunately, I don't see a bottle unless I'm staring at it, but these look like ones and stuff, so...
Unfortunately, your bottle is missing from pack number two.
Oh!
This is the bottom of the fucking shelf.
Where did that come from?
What?
Can I just slot it in without having to like...
Are you serious, you little fucking shit?
Is that really the bottom of the shelf?
Hold on, let me just go ahead to make sure there's no brown half fucking piece.
I swear to God, if that's the bottom of the fucking shelf, I'm ripping bag end out to put it down.
Oh, let me guess, and then what, the glass of wine's gonna fall out my ass crack next.
Are you serious?
Are you scolding me right now?
Where did that come from? Was that in...?
Right, can I gently somehow...
Careful now, I didn't get too easy.
Can I somehow very gently take out these shelves without destroying...
Without destroying the integrity of bag end?
Right, okay.
I mean, it's a very difficult kind of thing.
Pop that there.
If I have to redo the shelf, I'll redo the shelf.
Okay, gently.
Okay, good, we've got a big piece together.
Right, and then you can come off and you don't need to be supported anymore,
because I found a fucking mission, peace!
I don't know where it came from, I'm just happy it showed up.
I'm not mad at you, I'm just disappointed you were hiding from me, okay?
I have plans that I cannot speak of.
Speak of what?
Right, how the fuck do you put the shelf in here?
Lego experience? Is it?
Is this what everyone has to go through underneath?
That doesn't look right.
Because it's not, this piece comes out...
Come on, come back off the empty floor.
It's this knob.
My fingers are really starting to feel sore.
Is that normal?
Aren't I just such a dainty queen?
What are you doing?
Lego, you're killing me.
I don't think Lego is friendly to people with an old sense.
I'm not going to be able to play any of my video games properly.
Why are you playing like that when I'm playing one of these different games?
I can't say please forgive me.
Get the fucking shelf in.
Yeah, you've heard of Elf on a shelf.
You've heard of... have a month from something?
What?
I don't...
What am I looking at?
Right, so I don't know how I've done this, but...
I don't know how I've done that, but hey, well...
Look, it still came out the same.
Like, that's still what it asked for.
They are...
Right, there we go.
Gorgeous, stunning.
Don't fucking hate another piece of me again.
Hydration chick.
That looks right, right?
That is right.
My wee shelf.
My wee elf on a shelf.
Gorgeous.
Gorgeous, it's perfect.
No more magical shelf.
Strony on the Johnny is the best.
I can do nothing cool.
So I can hear birds on the roof right now.
They're probably like, where the fuck is there, dude?
Right, we've made back in.
Right, okay.
Now this is where things start looking a bit unfamiliar.
What the fuck is this?
It says I need that golden thing.
I need the big arch.
I need two big arches like that.
Okay, I'm definitely making the door.
That looks like...
I need four.
Seen through.
Oh, here we go.
Hold on.
I can't pick it up.
There we go.
You know, who's thought of nails?
Who's thought of nails?
Four black ones.
One wee door.
Wait, what?
Why would I need one door?
Maybe just do it in steps.
So part one to the...
What the fuck?
Could they not assemble this part?
I don't know what it's gonna click.
This doesn't look like it's gonna click.
Oh, there we go.
But that's not correct.
Like this.
This is rather curious, this stitch.
Okay, hold on.
I think...
Do they have to be a certain way?
Or am I just so weak?
I can't click it.
No, that can't be right.
No, turn it around, you dumbass.
Okay, turn it around if it doesn't fit.
Okay, there.
Step two, complete.
Step three, turn it around.
Step three, turn it over.
Turn it over.
What the fuck is going on?
Step four.
Place this...
Put the...
The hinge pieces?
Right.
Step four says...
What?
The door actually is gonna turn?
I'm getting nervous.
The door is gonna turn?
Can Lego do that?
I thought it was just stationary.
Hmm?
What?
Um...
I'm afraid something's no clicking.
It's like asking me to do that?
But it doesn't go on there.
What?
I'm not doing that.
This tends to be how doors work.
Welcome to Advanced Level.
Lego has a line of robotics too.
Uh...
What?
Mummy, for the car that I've built,
they made an engine that was moving forward?
What?
This is a bit too advanced for me.
Hold on. Bear with me. Bear with me.
Put a golden...
Put a yellow dot in a brown tooth.
A smooth brown tooth.
On a yellow dot.
And what would that be?
I know I'm skipping ahead a part.
I am...
Rather perplexed at the current agenda.
Of what the fuck I'm supposed to do.
I'm just going to do another part before that.
Cause I don't see...
I'm getting it.
So this is going to be the hinge.
But then what's going to hold it together?
These two long yellow parts.
These two long yellow parts are going to...
hold...
No, it's not. What's going to hold it together?
Hold.
What's going to hold it together?
Nothing holds it together other than sheer physics.
So that symbol says shove that up its thigh.
Oh!
You didn't hear that.
Oh my god.
Okay, j'ai compris.
J'ai compris. Dsol.
Dsol. J'ai compris.
It needs to do this, right?
Okay.
Okay, I was ramming it in from the side.
All I'm saying is...
I couldn't find a hole.
It was running...
Bro, please go in.
Right.
Okay, let's recalibrate.
Let's recalibrate.
Turn it.
I'm fucking done already.
Hold on.
Right.
What?
Okay, okay.
I'm sorry.
That's literally all I can see right now.
Oh!
What are you saying?
It was hard to find the right hole.
Inkling.
Ugh.
How far are we in?
Three hours.
Three fucking hours.
This is all I have to show for it.
I hope the next set is easier.
I swear. Part three and four, baby.
Right.
Back to the problem.
The fucking door.
Right.
Put it there.
Mm-hmm.
Right, okay.
And then it'll kiss, right?
And they'll make out and wherever we love each other.
Okay.
There you are.
The gap is today.
What?
The gap is tomorrow.
No, definitely not.
I mean...
Right.
So, to make them kiss,
then on one of them,
add to the top of the door,
and then
to...
to end blocks.
To end blocks.
End blocks.
Oh, I'm really far right now.
I'm not going to be a good girl, hold on.
Sorry, bright blue.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Oh, that's my stomach.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, no, don't do that.
Please don't ever do that again, my baby.
Okay.
No, I have to hold it.
Right.
And I take the door,
and where do I put it?
Here you are.
Please don't fall apart.
No.
I mean, it doesn't fit.
Have I fucked it?
I mean...
Mm-hmm.
Can you go in?
Uh...
It doesn't fit.
It's stuck off in place.
Why would you tell me to put the pillars in place?
No.
Oh!
Wait, the pillars hold it in!
Oh, my God, it doesn't clip!
Oh!
Wait, no.
Analyze?
Analyze the problem.
Analyze this right now.
No, that's not gonna work.
So, don't do it like that.
Just...
Yeah.
No.
Why would you make something that doesn't stay in?
Like, why would you make the windows...
Am I losing it?
Nine-year-olds, by the way.
A nine-year-old is supposed to be
fucking farting about it.
Oh, no.
No.
Don't lose it.
I have to hold it.
I can lose it shortly, but not yet.
I'm not all right now.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
Let me slab explore.
This is the real solution.
If you are ever needing help in this,
just do the slab explore.
Slab explore.
Bag end.
It might be crumbling around itself right now.
Okay.
Okay, and then let's...
Right, and then just rotate the window a little bit.
No, just...
Oh, now you don't want to fucking rotate?
Are you serious?
Fucking rotate.
It doesn't want to rotate?
Who's in zone?
Oh, yeah.
No!
Mm-hmm.
Piece of ghost.
Hold on, let me fix my window.
My window is breaking.
Mm-hmm.
Is this supposed to be this
pernickity?
Or am I messing up?
I always choose the bricks over the chicks, honestly.
Make sure they try the college at your beta
if it's not for me.
Oh, I never downloaded it.
I was like, I'm not rushing to play a video.
Like, so I was just releasing the video.
Mm-hmm.
And then it'll be my problem.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
And...
collect it.
Yep.
Ah, I messed it.
I messed it up.
Okay, that's the window.
It doesn't get
to touch anything else.
These pillows are what hold it up.
I messed it up.
Mm-hmm, yeah.
Down, down, down.
Up.
Something...
isn't...
flipping.
It's the window.
There's something about the window
that I've clearly fucked up.
I have to build on top of it as well.
Mm-hmm.
Yay.
If I fuck something up,
can someone open up a YouTube tutorial?
Uh...
Mommy, look at the underside of the arch.
There's a gap. The whole of the window pieces
needs to slide up in the gap.
Am I Spanish?
No.
I'm Spanish.
Mommy, look under
the side of the arch.
The side... look under
the side
of the arch.
It's supposed to sit on it.
Wait, oh, right, no.
Sorry, I thought I had it.
Mm-hmm, it's because
there's pillars holding it together.
Hold on, hold on. I know you can't see it.
Allow me... no, I know. Allow me to enter that.
I'm struggling.
Oh, and I'm breaking it. Hold on.
Sorry. Mommy needs to be selfish
for a moment and get this fucking window.
I think that's...
Oh!
The fucking garden's gone.
Someone fixed the front garden.
No! The fucking corner!
No! Don't do this to me now, please.
Don't do this to me now.
I've been so good.
I've done so well.
Please.
Stop this madness.
You're giving me a heart attack, Lego.
Don't. Right, just leave the window.
The window's gorgeous.
It's like really not
correct.
I don't see how it's supposed to
fucking sit on anything.
I mean, it does see.
Oh, piss off. Right.
Go away. I don't...
Okay.
Because you don't understand something,
it doesn't mean that it cannot be
the fact of life, okay?
Because you don't understand just fucking
ram it. Just keep ramming it.
Make it someone else's problem.
Just keep ramming it.
Solution will come to me.
Ha ha ha ha.
As long as the pillars
are where they are meant to be,
I think I can hate
that there's something wrong with this fucking window.
If the pillars
are where they're meant to be,
men men men men men.
If the pillars are where they're meant to be,
copy them.
Oh.
You know what would be really fun,
mommy?
Getting a modern LEGO set so we can build along with you?
No, cause you'll all be like,
Mummy, I've been waiting five minutes.
Stop it.
MB Bucket?
Thank you for becoming a member,
I'm so sorry I missed your notification.
Um, Mummy's having a mental breakdown,
I'll wear a bit of plastic.
I'm sorry, son.
Remove one of the arches,
then slide in the transparent part in the groove,
in the remaining arch,
then put back the other arch between the arches.
What the fuck are you on about?
Thank you for the...
What are you on about?
Slade what?
My fucking painters?
Sl- an arch?
Right, okay.
Hold on.
So we're calling this sand bit a pillar.
Right?
So when you say remove an arch,
you mean one of these?
The sixth window arch?
Or is this wrong?
That's not the arch.
This is not what you mean.
No, not that one.
Okay, so you mean the sand pillars?
Okay, yes.
Is the grass not?
Hold on, the grass isn't right.
Okay.
The pillar.
Remove one of the pillars.
One pillar has been removed.
I said one pillar has been removed.
Okay.
Let me read that, don't know.
Stoney, remove one of the arches,
then slide in the transparent part
in the groove,
in the remaining arch.
What does that mean?
I'm gonna have to start fucking discord calling yous.
Then slide in the transparent part.
Oh, I can't.
Slade in the transparent part.
Where?
Where would I slide it in?
I was already in.
It was already in.
Remove the arch first to see.
So now I'm removing the arches, the curvy part, mommy.
Okay, so it's not the pillars, right?
I'm taking the pillars out.
Fuck you.
Remove one of the arches.
Okay.
Then what?
Then, Stoney, remove one of the arches,
then slide in the transparent part
in the groove of the remaining arch.
Like, there's no end.
Oh, the whole thing.
Like that.
Oh, the thing goes inside it.
Oh, my God.
Like, the whole thing goes inside it.
We got there.
Right, okay, back to building D.
I love building Legos.
Legos are so fun.
Okay, let me just fix the grass.
I got it!
Okay, let's...
Let's just come in full, right?
Okay, back to you.
Now that we have a frame and everything,
I can adjust it again.
Okay.
We put that there, and then we put the pillars.
We got the pillar there.
Okay, then I need two skinny green ones.
I have a long one, so I'm not...
Two skinny green ones.
Okay.
And then they go on top,
around this brown paint part.
You still see? You can.
So they go...
A very nice gay dork.
He dated me.
He gave me a painted...
A painted dork.
Oh, it appears I'm experiencing what is known as severe shoulder pain.
I think they're not with us.
Okay.
Wait, why aren't you going in?
What's holding you back?
It's going to...
Excuse me?
There's a window facing the wrong way.
Hold on.
Don't worry, I just need to turn it.
Okay.
And then like this.
Ah, so there's a man.
I am so smart.
It's in marking.
In marking.
Okay, we did this.
We are finally out of that section.
Never again do we have to revisit that section.
Okay, we need two archways which are in your dog bowl.
Like so.
I'm going to burp.
That's a terrible burp.
Hold on, hydration check.
I'm going to rotate my shoulder a little bit.
The top of the brown window needs to be...
How did you spell that?
My little eyeball can't do it and I'm right in front of it.
You forgot to place the transparent piece in the window.
Okay.
This?
Oh Jesus, what the fuck was that?
I think it was my microphone.
Sorry, I scared myself.
Okay, the transparent part in the window.
I can do that.
Ignore that the grass keeps coming off it's me.
Hold on.
I need to be like...
Can you go in here?
Okay.
I can't figure that when I...
Wait, what was the instructions?
Twist it in.
Release me!
Oh, well, I didn't have to twist that much.
Okay, let's pop on the grass again for the eighth time.
As long as it's still together, it's really all I care about.
I'm just going to press down to make sure nothing's
planning on flying away at this point in time.
I've been...
Wait, did I even take a picture?
I will be so much better.
You worked so hard and so did Admiral.
Please make sure you get enough rest and be healthy.
Yes, this week is definitely a rest week for me.
Um...
I hope you don't mind the shorter streams.
I feel like really new when I do them.
MP Bucket, thank you for the extended membership!
Peace out!
Um...
The green pieces taste like green apple.
Please do not eat.
Quick, eat a piece.
Wait, why are you eating a piece?
Because I'm looking away.
Um...
Can I have one of the spare pieces?
I'm hungry.
Or do you need food?
I have...
Unironically, I have chicken tendies.
They're like the best thing ever here.
Eh, right.
Okay.
Add these tellers to these onto the teller.
Oh, bit wobbly.
Bit wobbly, yeah?
Bit wobbly, nobly.
Like a tiny, whiny biscuit.
Twist it.
Like it.
Turn it.
Bop it.
Q.
Thank you, the beauty lord, for the knyup.
Okay, add those pieces.
Up next.
One by three green brick.
But you'll need two of them.
Player.
Add them where?
Here.
E.T.
It only attaches to this little bit there,
which isn't really doing it for me.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, fine.
We've added it.
Step 67.
Do two.
Two.
Half.
I don't know, six by one.
It's not six by one, is it?
Because it's like a fake piece.
One of them.
And then get another one that looks the exact same.
Okay.
Now, whoa.
Sorry.
I just realized that bull is really close to the microphone.
It's probably really light in your ear.
I wonder how much energy Stony would have in an actual night in a five.
I used to be a waitress.
I used to work in a care home.
Those were 12 hours shifts.
Those were very difficult, difficult, and difficult.
You can bang these two and stick them at the top of the window.
I, for the lack of better words, was just a zombie when I did the normal nine to five.
Like, I am tired after stream.
Like, I do lie down.
I have a nap and then like I'll deal with like whatever the girls are asking for me.
Like, after I've had a lie down because I'm just tanning.
Like, is it decompressors or?
Because I like being quiet after stream because I'm very loud and not annoying loud though,
but just loud in terms of like, I don't normally, I don't know, it's not normally just comedy.
I don't normally like talk with much or do this thing, you know.
So I do enjoy being a little bit quiet.
Wait, what?
Hold on.
Something's not good.
What was that?
And then a cube above the doorway.
And then one this one.
Must be.
If it fits, I sits.
You're often swapped between super quiet and super loud.
Basically, I get really excited when I get to be with you.
Which makes me like super happy and like, oh my god, basically.
But once stream is over, like I normally go get Gimli and Vigo and I let them outside
and they need the toilet and if they need more food, I'll give them more.
And then I lie down in my bed and I do what I call my TikTok green rotine.
And it's just like quiet, like I just, no words, no nothing.
Sorry, I just really can't see that.
Sorry, again, it's okay.
So we've now flattened this window.
Typical Aussie's girlfriend talks a lot with boyfriend there and then doesn't talk when he's not there.
Honestly, really fun, honestly.
I'm just like, okay, well, now what?
And then once I've had enough TikTok time, like my brain will just tell me enough.
It's like, okay, I've had enough.
And then I'll be like, right, okay, what am I doing for food?
And most likely it's take away because you don't have time to be doing too much.
Right, what?
Beam.
It says I need three named beans.
That's two, four, six, eight, and then nine.
And then I need three.
Oh, I think I thought one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
And then I need three poopy studs.
One, two.
And then a third poopy stud.
Okay.
What do I do?
Oh, and I need three arches.
Okay.
And I'm like, use me.
Some of us are busy rambling.
Mama, you need to eat healthy.
Cooked meals.
I did well making that soup, but just, I don't feel like putting that in.
I don't feel like putting effort.
Not just, not, right, before anyone dooms when I say this.
Not to like be fucking dramatic or anything, but like, I want to put in effort for stream.
I want to put in effort for you.
I want to have a good time with you and all that.
What, I didn't, like, as soon as I finish stream, I'm just like, that's the best.
I just perish after stream.
Where did the third one come in?
I'm just making a third one.
Of the truth.
And like, I made that soup and then I got the chicken to make a soup round two.
And I just never made that.
And then those veggies ended up getting me.
And then I felt bad.
I put them out to the salute.
Learning as many recipes.
I think, honestly, my solution is probably to go hell for leather and make frozen meals.
Like, you know how those folk do frozen meal food prep?
I saw a breakfast burrito one and I was like, I could probably last on that.
I used to eat fajitas every single day for a very, very long time.
Fajitas you can make in one pan.
And you microwave the tortillas.
Oh, that goes on.
Well, I'm actually glad I found that third piece because, yeah, this is kind of more structural stuff that would have been
balanced then without the bottom.
Okay, we're putting...
My hand's getting sore.
I'm getting like pain in here.
Gimli, I heard that.
I think the background's coming together, though.
Like, actually, I could see myself role-playing in here so well.
Why he becomes golem?
I don't know.
Don't question that.
What?
What was I saying?
I forgot.
I'm looking for the...
I should have probably put a bit of background music in it.
You know what? How about you open up on YouTube?
Just put the Shire music on one hour loop.
And then that will come for you during this video.
Oh, Brian?
Yeah, that's pretty much it.
Pretty much it, some stream ends.
I'm just like, yep, quiet.
Rest well, those who sleep. Thank you for hanging in.
You'd volunteer to cook for me?
Yeah, you make me spaghetti.
My mum made me spaghetti when I first moved out.
She would get annoyed at me because every time I saw her, she'd be like,
I'm losing weight, stunning.
And I'd be non-purpose.
I just couldn't be asking anything for myself.
I just don't care. I don't care.
But I care about making you happy and hanging out.
Shit, I got fucking spoiled to this Lego set.
If you don't know the lore, I was in a membership stream
and I was talking about Lego or something and I looked up the set.
I was like, oh, it's $500.
I'm not going to spend it on myself.
An anonymous or anon, yeah, I guess anon.
Literally just gave them money over and I'm like, what the fuck?
I'm like, yeah, damn.
I don't deserve this, but it's very nice though.
This is very very nice.
I'm sorry if I sound tired or like, I promise you I'm not bored.
Yeah, I'm not bored.
I apologize if I sound tired.
And that is because, oh, don't do this to me now.
Don't do this to me now.
I don't think it's here.
You deserve it, mommy.
You deserve the nice stuff in life too.
You just don't give yourself that one.
I don't know why.
I don't know why you don't think you deserve the nice things.
Here's a missing piece.
You're fucking bam.
Can I hide that I have a missing piece of question?
It's a long piece.
A square.
I think there's a one tiny missing piece, but thankfully.
Thankfully, each no-
Are you squinting me right now?
Because I think I can hate that.
Right.
Is extroverts need two hours with people part of a mono introvert too?
I don't know.
It's not.
I suppose would it be?
Would it be anything else?
More like a pair of hair.
But I'm more serious now.
Thank you for the tip of the lucky person.
An anon, right?
Maybe involve us into your cooking if that gives you energy to cook.
So I'm doing a bacon stream next month.
I'll literally just spoil on it.
I'm going to see if I can think of unity stuff to do.
I've got two unity plans coming up.
I only have one of these.
I'd rather leave it out if it's going to stand out with a suit.
Nothing is falling out.
Wait, why are we crooked?
Oh right, because of my terrible jokes.
I was like, excuse you.
There's not a flat green piece in your dog bowl.
And there's not a...
Oh no, idiot.
I'm going to leave it.
I'm going to leave it out.
So it looks like it's supposed to be like that.
Okay, time for some physics engine stuff that I never comprehend.
Grab the door, got it.
Two black hinges and a sandstone.
I'm going to get some furniture that I would buy now.
Thank you, Anon, for the tip.
There's a small green in the bowl.
No, it's asking for a flat green.
There's only one.
These are too slow. These have two knobs on them.
Then you can't wait it is.
Wait, wait.
I think I'm being trolled, right?
It says sandstone.
Door.
And then...
No, one knob.
Okay, I'm not being trolled.
I take it back. I'm sorry. I'm just very doom and gloom right now.
So...
Right, one. Get the pieces together.
Sandstone.
One goes that way.
There's this way.
Right.
Two.
Attractive women cooking McMailman go-brew.
Wait.
What did I just see there?
Attractive women cooking makes male main brain go-brew.
Wait, I need to go online. Good night.
We've had a good run.
Right, and then two.
Sandstone.
Go up and down there.
I think I'm definitely going to run that fast with this thing.
Right, I'm being trolled.
There's another missing piece.
See here? This one doesn't have any knobbly wobbly biscuits on it.
Oh, because it's on the top of this fucking thing.
Excuse me.
I can't laugh.
I'm not allowed to.
Can you just come up?
Can you come up?
Okay, okay, hold on.
Sorry.
There's a.
And one of the.
One of it was like a caption with the sound.
And it was like,
when I'm clutching up for my team,
but they don't know I'm a sandwich maker.
And it was like, no, no, I can't laugh.
And I was like, oh my God.
That's so true.
I don't like talking.
Unfortunately, I don't know.
I didn't have time for video games before I became a VTuber.
And now I get to experience all these.
I get to experience new games.
I get to play games with you guys.
It makes me really happy.
If you didn't know,
yeah, I kind of seem to,
you know,
I didn't know yet.
I kind of seem to enjoy doing things with you.
You know,
you love this set as a child.
Well, it was unbelievably hard.
Thank you.
I'm pinning that.
Hold on a minute.
I'm pinning that comment.
I'm pinning that fucking comment.
I need to.
I need to pin it.
You don't understand.
I need to fucking pin it.
Where's that comment?
It's unbelievably hard.
Thank you.
Someone who has came
and done this set before
proving that it's fucking hard.
You've done this set before
Is that me?
Oh, I was like,
why can't I hear something talking?
It's me.
Sorry, it's me.
Well, apparently my brain's capacity is
because this is the fucking area where you can
wrap it up.
Hold on.
I'm going to have another split
and see what happens next.
Wait, he said it went hard?
Oh, no.
Oh my god, I actually love this set.
Legos went unbelievably hard.
No.
Fuck off.
I'm pinning. Get out of here.
Get out of here. I don't want to read that.
You take the wrong message.
You get nothing.
Get out of here.
No.
I was fucking validating.
Someone who's done the thing
and knows how unbelievably awkward
and hard it is for no reason.
Take that piece.
Take this piece. Right.
The brown and the black.
What do they do together?
The brown goes on the knob side.
The black
goes like this.
Okay.
Can you go in?
Okay, and then four.
I spent most of my life without pet folk.
The folk is going on.
If a girl made me food, I would cry.
I mean, shit, you want some cheesy puffs?
I can fucking
pop that shit up real quick.
What am I doing? It says door.
It just shows me a picture of it.
Turn that shit over and let me see
if I attach it. You already know what I'm going to...
Fuck it up.
You already know.
And I guess I just go for it.
Wait a minute.
I'm brain dead.
I can't do this.
Okay.
Yeah, that looks right.
Okay, then on the back.
Two black lanes.
Three blind nights.
What the fuck is this?
And to put them here.
Like that.
Why would that... What would that do?
Hmm? What would that do?
I'm scrounging for any bit of
validate. How dare you?
How dare you be so... How dare you tell the truth?
I've had enough out of you.
Silence.
Okay.
God, remember that
puff it went so viral?
Right, now what happens?
Turn it back over and put a gold
on the door.
I mean, that looks pretty golden to me.
Gold? Wait, what one?
There's a yellow yen.
I mean, I can always take it off.
It's not a big deal.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, come on.
It's squeezy?
Bro, how are
VTubers so relaxed doing this?
Ah, I'm getting angry.
I'm like enjoying it.
But excuse me?
Who?
Where did it go? It despawned.
Oh, there it is. I found it.
It's here.
How are VTubers like?
I just love building Legos.
Right, well...
I like making progress.
Why is there no progress?
How's it like, go in the...
Right, go fucking.
I'm putting the yellow knob one on.
Fuck you.
And before this is the correct one.
Oh my god, it's so pernickety because I'm a nail.
I'm going to leak this gen 2
fucking talents name.
Just to curse her out when she fucking
spawns in.
Go in.
Right.
It's not right.
And it's my head clearly because what is this?
Why is it not going in?
You can see I'm putting it in between the 4
and the middles and literally
snapping my fingers. Is it because I'm weak to be honest?
What the gen 2
do to deserve that, bro?
They didn't even pick to yet and I'm ready to curse them out.
It's the nail colour.
Go in.
Right, I'm picking another one.
Surely the problem is the stud
and it's not me, the common denominator
to all the problems.
Surely the common D...
No.
That actually hurt.
Oh, no.
I got...
Right, there's no gold bit on the door.
Okay.
There's no gold bit on the door.
Hi, Brad.
I think that's the star destroyer.
Thank you, Baylor, for the set.
How does the knob work in the middle of the door?
It fucking doesn't go on.
The nails are cute, at least.
All right, girls, cute.
Fucking pretty much.
Right.
I put this one wrong. Are you joking?
Oh, I put it on wrong.
Fucking gold bit.
And do you know how I know I've put it on wrong?
Because look at Gandalf's mark.
Remember in the moot?
Sorry, the light is really bad.
Remember in the movie when Gandalf marks the door?
Is that the...
The part you can see?
And then Bilbo was like, I just painted that.
Literally, there's the mark.
Right, okay, let's just put the door on.
Let's just put the door on.
Wait, hold on, wait.
Does it rotate?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh. Hold on.
Okay, okay.
So this isn't... Wait, no, I need to...
I don't have another character yet.
Unless you want to play a sword. You don't fuck it.
You can be the sword. I'll rule play. Use the sword.
Are you ready?
Okay, so you're the sword.
And this is me. And you go
knock, knock, knock.
And I'll be like...
And then I open the door.
Oh my, yes, of course. And you come.
Refling. Oh my.
And then you come in and then you just ink
everywhere of excitement because you know what's coming next.
I enjoyed that rule play. We should rule play more.
Okay.
Next, I will...
Oh, I'll say cheers with our dog bowls.
We're to decorate
bag end a bit further.
Okay, I can do that.
There's a mistake on the sword. Get a fucker.
Oh, there's not a mistake on that sword.
It's actually just me. I'm just dumb.
I'm just dumb.
I love you. You're a dork.
Bro, I'm an aggressive dork.
Right, let's first up
bag end. It's looking a bit shite.
If this was on that bed and breakfast
British TV show, I completely
thought my name was that.
It was like people owned like bed and breakfast.
Oh my god, stop. This is so pretty.
Ow.
That's really starting to bend
my thumb back if I'm doing anything.
Can you?
Okay.
Can you go in?
Wait, is this got a space in between it?
It does. Okay.
I'm trying to put it in the corner.
I didn't even go in the corner. Sorry.
I'm trying to let you see what I'm trying to do.
It gets so dark in bag end.
Can someone light a candle? God damn.
Okay, there we go. Boom.
Okay.
Take the potion
and put
some lids on it.
I'm gonna, I need to fart so badly.
Please excuse me.
Excuse me one moment.
Oh, and of course I scared it away
the moment I said that. Like I announced it to the class.
Potatoes.
Boiling mushrooms.
Don't me out.
How dare you.
You wanna smell my voluptuous methane?
Oh my God, this looks like a sprite.
Oh, this is like a baby Christmas tree.
Oh Christmas tree.
Why?
Right. I'm being trolled.
Why are none of the studs
going on correctly?
I can't believe I'm the problem.
No.
Right.
Gollum one.
I wish I could tell you this.
Oh, we got it. It farted.
I don't know if you heard that audibly but it too did.
Right. Green potion in the corner.
I'm in the corner
Watching all your bad and
I
This is drawn yellow
but this is clearly
orange.
Okay.
The stud is a-
Not muting is an act
of companionship.
How dare you.
Testing my
Mr. Lord.
I mean, it looks like it's kind
of been opened and he's like not put that lid
back on so I can't get it.
Oh!
Hold on.
It's in the corner.
There we go.
Baggins starting to look a bit more
lived in.
Look at that.
Gorgeous stuff.
And look, the best part
in you come.
We do not come
into my bag end.
That's the- I have a new name for Marshall.
Right. Enough. Don't laugh at that.
That's not funny.
No strongy.
You can't just say you're a funny YouTuber.
Oh, cheers.
Just because you crack jokes all the time.
Right. Four.
What the fuck?
Four of these. One,
two, three,
four.
And then four
of these. One,
two, four, one.
Oh, I think I'm ovulating today
for no particular reason.
So I'm doing that.
I'm feeling-
Feeling rather slimy for a cuttlefish.
I would, but still couldn't.
Would
be the one ring to bend the bow.
There's a green piece four
units long
from some sets before you forgot.
There's a green piece four
units long. This
might be-
There's like an extra pieces I've got.
I've got extra pieces from the first set as well.
And I'm
not a worried Barbie
about the
I
think it's extra.
Oh, no, you're Ray Rieflin.
Holy fuck, you guys have to like
eagle vision. This is like Assassin's Creed
and you're the eagle. How do you
do that?
I don't know how you see that. How do you see that?
Literally bird's-eye view of the
shit. Fucking front row seats.
I don't know how you do that.
Are they smiley face in the bowl?
No.
Aww, let me see a little smile.
Yeah.
We gamers, we jump you.
We jump your ass.
Rain the crap. Right, okay.
Put these together
and bang them with a little two piece.
I can do that.
Okay, we're doing the door at back end.
Oh, I saw.
I saw.
Right, no more doing insults
in other languages. I've been really bad at that.
I just don't mind.
Oh, so it's like a blade in your heart.
For most
people.
Okay.
We now have the entrance
way to back end.
Right, collect it.
Do a flip.
Okay, we're flipping it gently because
the grass keeps coming flying off
and that's because of me. Okay, I'm the problem.
I am the problem.
I'm the problem.
Okay, now
just
like that.
I mean
it's what the diagram seems
that they're going to hold up.
Wait.
No, I don't think we can hold in it.
Not like
visually.
I think I can
Shragg in the bag.
Why are you so close?
There's so much to bring along in this room.
That was fun. Sorry if you heard that.
There's an internal control.
I
love it to pick anyway.
It was in the collars
in the dog bowl.
Choose your enemy.
That was a cute one, Anon.
Thank you for the tip.
I'll give you that one. That was a cute one.
Ever thought of making a video teaching
Scots? Yes.
Now that my
things are starting to come.
Is my hair in the fucking Lego set?
Oh for...
No, right. It was on it.
I swear if I like wedged my hair in between two blocks.
I was going to lose it.
If I don't lose it,
I'm going to lose it. Everybody gets two.
Oh, it does sit on.
Right, okay. It sits on. We've got the front door.
It's a bit skewed with, but hey,
this is very difficult.
Right, one,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
Okay, and then what do I do?
Put it at the bottom of the window.
Bottom of the window.
Put the wee hang on.
At the bottom of the window. I'll teach you some Scots right now.
To say
thing, you say hang,
but so we don't pronounce the G
at the end of I and G a lot.
So
if I was in accent mode
if I
needed you to pass me the
remote controller for
the TV
I would say
go and
go together.
Go and together is goon.
Goon, giz us
give us giz us
us is plural, but
it means me in that particular
accent structure. Goon, giz us
I've already forgotten what the original
word I was trying to teach it. What was
I trying to teach it?
What was the word? The remote, the
controller. Goon, giz us the remote.
What? No, what was I saying?
I've already forgotten my accent structure.
Sorry.
Goon, giz us. Oh, the hang, the hang.
There we go. The thing, the remote.
Goon, giz us the hang.
So basically
please pass me the remote.
Goon, giz us the hang.
That's
Scots. That's why I don't
teach it because
you would have no idea what I'm on about the last time.
Can you come?
Can you?
What do you need?
Oh, the window's fucking open.
Right, close the window Bilbo. It's
late, there's orcs out. Okay, fucking
close the window.
It's like Minecraft, as soon as you got
like a dirt block around you.
The hang,
the hang. Goon, giz us
the hang. You'd still
spell it with a G written down
but you wouldn't pronounce the G.
But the thing is it also depends
on context because if I was asking for
your willy, your willy,
your willy, your willy, Minky's
sausage, that would still make
the same sentence.
I would say Goon, giz me
your hang.
Be fun. Goon, giz me your hang.
Get a move on.
That still works as a sentence structure.
It's just context.
Goon, I've just broke this.
I don't know what broke. Something just broke.
Put them back, right.
Just fucking
hold on.
I'm sure
I'll be fine.
Well, that's it. We're going to continue to
build on
foundation. That isn't stable.
Go giz us your willy.
That was kind of, willy's
like, oh chin chin
like, young
way to say it. You wouldn't really say it
that.
On this side
put the wee one.
Say no more.
And on the other side
put the big one.
I feel
unasculated. Why is one side getting more
than one?
Ah, I've no got a schedule.
Nope,
he's gone.
Honestly, it's kind of go hot. Definitely need
a future Scottish term
in all of the extreme. I mean, I'll teach
it English if you want.
It's English to me. Do you know what I mean?
Like, you know what I mean.
It's not
Scottish.
It implies Alba.
I just made a mess on my Jessica Alba.
Ladies and gentlemen.
You're the one
you're the one
who they came to see
back
back by popular demand.
How does it feel? Is it like now?
What?
I
have an extra...
No.
I can't have an extra one of these. What is it?
It says use window there.
That one. No, can't be.
Can't be that one.
We already built it in.
And it can't be this one because it's mentioned
on this page.
Doorway!
Got it. Doorway.
Got it.
Oh my god. We finished part two.
Are you going to hear me part?
He's drowning. Your hands aren't sweaty all the time.
Oh yeah?
Now you're going to tell me to go clap.
I'll do it. Don't think I won. Right, we did it.
This...
It took us to get through one
part one
and it took us
four fucking hours.
And look at all these leftover pieces.
Well, Bilbo doesn't count.
But yeah, there's like
random assortments of
stuff.
I mean, I guess
I'm going to have to pour you out because I don't
need yous. We did what we had to do.
Bilbo, you come to the cycle.
Right, we're going to do
the next one. I'm not
quitting.
Okay, quit. Are you re-flin?
It's literally taking me two hours
to prepare a coffee.
Where's the other manual?
Oh, don't tell me I lost it.
Oh.
Okay, I got it.
I can't clap.
Oh, it feels nice.
Hold on. Wait, let me stand up and stretch.
I have to bloody go.
You want me to clap?
Oh, okay. Wait, can I do it without it?
I can't.
Is that what you want?
I love how this goes. I only discovered that
because of you guys. I can do it on command.
I don't know if it's a good idea.
Good girl.
How do I put color?
Sorry, I'm literally standing up.
I don't know if you can do a lot of doing this.
Well, this is good to throw it over it.
Yeah, this is it. Get the door.
Oh, shit, that was a really loud sorry.
Sorry. See, this is what I'm going to have on you.
Pass, cat, feet.
What do you mean feet? I did a whole stream about feet.
I'm probably going to do another one because I'm not
a catarina. I love her story.
But if you come by, I'm like, I don't know if you can do it.
Oh, I'm not fucking sure there's an agony.
Okay.
Right.
As reeflings
are my witness,
we will do the same method where I put
all the big ones in you
and then I'll put the wee ones in me.
No correlation to real life.
Fucking hell, what are we up against?
Alright, I'll put that in there.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, well, I see Gandalf.
I think this party's about to get bigger.
Hold on.
Okay, this manual...
Oh.
Is there any more sex I'd like?
Or am I being trolled?
Sorry, let's just...
Let me break it.
Let me browse the catalogue.
Is there any more sex I would want?
See, this is what I needed.
These little fucking scenes
where they're tiny and toty.
That's what I needed to do.
No, this fucking...
Oh, I just gave myself a paper cut.
Are you sure?
See, you fight a...
naughty sequence, fighting over the ring.
Rivendale.
Kind of yours.
Don't care.
What is this? A fucking...
I'll be finished.
Let's see if we can finish up.
Right, put Gandalf together.
Okay, let's put Gandalf together.
Oh, no, we've got three hobbits.
We've got three hobbits in this one.
She's feeding his little Tony to it.
I think that would still take you three hours.
Brap without cake
and clap without hands at the same time.
Brap without cake? What?
Brap without...
Take care of your shoulders, especially the cut.
Yeah, my right shoulder.
For mommy, let me clean your cut.
Yeah, mommy's handy.
It's not showing up, though.
It's my middle finger cut right through it,
but it's not showing up and I'm like,
oh, maybe I've got wings up.
Right, let's put Gandalf together.
He's somewhere in here.
Oh, there's buffers we have!
Oh, my God, even more plastic.
No.
Right, let's get his we have.
He must have got special need for it.
There's Old Man Beard.
That looks like Gandalf to me.
He seems like a determined fellow.
Oh, is we head drawn?
Head drawn.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, my God, he's been locked
in the carbon-freezing chamber for how long?
Who the fuck is behind this?
Out you come.
What?
Hello?
Oh, they're capes.
Are these...
Yeah?
Okay, um...
They look like capes,
but not capes.
Well, that would be for Gandalf.
That would be for you and then buffer,
and then I have a blonde...
I'm gonna put it in my bowl for now.
Okay, I did get a paper cut,
and I feel like...
Alright, Gandalf's hat.
Got it.
And then your body.
And then buffer's hat.
Can you flatten out?
Oh, my God, he's like...
Oh, he's covered in...
I mean, I guess he is actually a veteran battler.
And then your buffer.
Both of these moves.
Yes, I'm a child.
Okay, let's put the party together.
Um...
Coming up.
So you better get this packet.
Right, we can put Gandalf together.
So let's do that.
Right, put Gandalf's body in.
Okay.
Not a good time to lose one's head.
Don't tear them.
Not that I was planning on.
Is it like this?
Where you cross the paper over?
Oh, my God, this paper's made how many years ago?
I assume that's how I do it.
And then you put his head through the net.
Oh.
Let's find out.
Yeah, that seems right.
Oh, this.
Right, let's try again.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Try, try, try as you make.
Brain.
Gun.
Can you not see how much I'm struggling right now?
And you want me to upgrade my tier to Gun-Puzz?
I am struggling so hard with Lego.
For nine-year-olds!
And you want Gunpla?
Is there sexy Gunpla?
Is there sexy one?
Thank you for the tip.
Gun-Hole Warith.
Brave.
I can't put the cape on.
The cape is upside down.
I don't know.
Like...
Is it?
Because it's not...
Oh, no, I didn't...
No, I can't laugh.
Please.
What the...
That's the best I've got.
Gandalf, seal the deal.
Shavonia.
Right, and then put your wee hat on.
Where's your beard?
Did you shave it off?
Oh my god, no buffers parts are in here.
I can see his little mane in his thing.
Okay, okay.
I'll empty this one out.
There's something in here.
Right.
As you're my witness.
Please.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Oh my...
Fuckin' shoulders, really.
I'm gonna be in... What am I doing tomorrow,
by the way, stream-wise?
Just so I know how much I can fuck my shoulder
up right now.
On...
Right, and then that's his beard.
Wait a minute.
Oh no, it goes to his cape, his beard, his head.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Ugh, might take more.
His beard?
What, like, it just sits there?
Oh, oh yeah.
Oh yeah, he went to Spain.
Without this.
Mm-hmm.
And then his head.
And then a wizard's cap.
Oh my god.
That'll do.
Hold on as we...
Mouse shouldn't be.
That looks like him. Okay, there we go.
We go out.
We'll role-play at the end.
And we'll watch an Austin Poe.
Chain together, solo in Austin Poe.
You should rest your shoulder.
It's... It's because of the way I hold it.
I don't know why.
I insist on, like,
is it hunched?
Like, is it hunched?
I like hunched my shoulders.
And it...
My right one's being hunched right, man.
It's a...
It's starting to be jeep.
That's another Scottish word.
I can teach you jeep. It's being made jeep.
Where the f...
Why do I only have one pair of legs?
Well, he's in a wheelchair now.
I only have one pair of legs.
Woffer's legs are brown,
so this is definitely Balan's.
So...
Get out of here.
And Balan has a sword.
E.K.
Balan.
More like
I think...
Wait.
No, that one goes on top.
Okay, we just got a prank played on.
So he's covered in scars because he's actually a war veteran.
But...
He should be retired.
But, you know, he is.
Any other time.
Right, and then what? Okay, that's him made.
Balan is up. So Woffer...
Unless
his little crippled legs are in here.
I think we have
our first
Colbert officially claiming disability.
Which is fantastic.
Stable Hobbit.
Oh my...
His legs are brown.
I'm combing
under Balan's sword.
Balan
He loves his physicality in Hobbit.
He believes everyone has a right to live.
Right, sorry, I'm giving
I'm having a stroke, it was nice knowing that.
Cheers.
Sorry, I just did a really big
sniff layer which I'm not
supposed to do into the microphone.
But I did it.
Right, okay, we've just got a disabled Hobbit.
Where's his face gone?
Are you squidding me right now?
I don't know, are you squidding me right now?
I just really enjoyed the satisfaction
of the game.
I found it really
satisfying just reloading and then
try and get to the next area.
So I was just gonna like...
I wanna place this on my own.
So I was just gonna do it
and have fun news
because
can I get in?
I can.
I'm gonna do it on my Streamsnap account
because in case there's somewhere
I get stuck because
when I ended it on the collab
Misma
was the location where we had to
sling off of it together
and I was like, ew.
So I might very quickly get a Streamsnap refund
and
I don't know.
And then we'll watch Austin Powers
The Spy who's
or something like that. I can't remember.
I've not seen it before.
So before you expect me to be like quoting what's coming up
Oh, his legs!
Before you expect me to
be
like
Oh, there we go.
Okay, here we go.
Why do you look angy?
Angy?
Is that the wrong face?
Is this
swollen?
No, it's not.
Does he have a different face on the other side?
He does. He smells in there.
I'm not sure that...
I thought the buffer
is in there.
Is it swollen or something?
Oh my God!
Fucking Harry Potter up in here.
That's a query though.
I am on your back.
What? Do they all have?
That was fucking creepy.
There were certain things on your back when we walked.
Thank you, Nero, for the tip.
So we're doing that tomorrow.
That'll be better.
Okay, we're doing the front
of the house now.
We need
four
wee skinny bits.
Not that long.
That was a bit too long.
What are you trying to achieve?
I'm not sure.
Oh my God!
It's just like the barrels and Lego Lord of the Rings.
Where they have all the weaponry inside it.
I didn't even know they had two faces.
I was like, uh, hold on a minute.
Wait, so this...
Is that why Bilbo looks so weird?
Okay, yeah.
Literally, I was like, why is he so weird?
He isn't his own history.
Everyone,
we're playing happy families.
Put your happy faces on.
I won't tolerate anything less than fake happiness.
I'm going to put your game face
No, not that one.
The very piece I need to just
flew out of my hand somewhere.
Oh, there it is.
I need one.
I need two gray squares.
Which I guess are over here.
Because they're not in your doggy bow.
I need six poop studs.
You know.
Dos.
Cuatro.
Cinco.
Se.
Oh wait, was it Cinco?
Undos.
I know it's kind of hard to stay
there all of the day.
He asked for a tattoo, yeah.
He asked for a 13,
but instead they drew a 31.
And I've been saying,
you know
you might never know that every day.
The world knows
what I've been so
hey, hey, do whatever you think.
And that's all that I need.
That's all that I need.
That's all that you can
a cappella cariol too.
And all that
does stand pretty flat
for a white dog.
What is that?
A bit of fluff.
Go, go.
I'm taking that fluff with me.
Okay, mama, that's my family.
You can be the puffy one over here all the way.
Whoa, what the fuck? You can't combine.
You can't combine the special
interest.
That is illegal.
That's...
That's the penalty.
You can't combine
the naughty
and the interest.
I promise
we will do karaoke soon to you.
Soon to you we'll do karaoke.
I'm gonna force you to do my karaoke first
because it'll be songs that I know
like
a rabie and I
like a rabie
more often than not
our hotter than not
in a lot of good
words.
Yes, we'll do karaoke.
Um...
I'm a bit wary of
DMCA streams.
Did you hear about that?
Fucking...
Did you hear about Iron Mouses?
Vodchannel got DMC newt.
Um...
They were saying like...
So people were
think, thought it was about
this ball for heaven.
I did put a table.
Folk were like, oh, it's cause
someone hurt a doc's herself
or that as if she can't just use the fucking
company's info.
Um...
And then the person
who owned Vodchannel came
out and was like, no,
it's cause of the react Andy
and it was like...
I mean
it's a shame cause that
that was a Vodchannel.
That was an inc- where the fuck is this one?
Um, it's a shame cause
like that Vodchannel had like
literally everything on it and obviously
you make money on Vods like
I know sometimes you might be like, oh, why is
this streamer bothered about like
a Vod not making...
Like if it got copyright struck cause
oh, it's only gonna make 200 views
and
you know, which isn't even a dollar
or statistically.
Okay, there is, I found it, thank god.
Um...
Oh my god, I get to make a little
pathway.
Aw, this is so cute.
Put a little stepping stones up
to our house together and back in.
Um...
Like I know it would be like, oh, why is
it like such a big deal? It's like
insane passive income. YouTube ads
I get that they're fucking annoying, trust
me, I'm on it too, they're
annoying. Um...
But like, can if you have YouTube premium
I'm actually gonna talk about this in a
short when it comes to ASMR.
Um...
Your YouTube premium, depending
goes like, the majority of the money goes to
whoever you watch the most, so like, say if
you left your YouTube premium
completely on me for whatever reason.
If you're like, ah, I just need more of that
Scottish accent. Um...
Like it adds up as passive income
and passive income, i.e.
don't have to stream for it, didn't have the plan or anything
like that, like that's why ASMR is also like
a really good thing. Cause people, if you
make a good roleplay, people will come back
and listen to it. Um...
And you get paid
way more, way way more
for a return
viewer than you
do a new viewer, to make sense.
So if you click on the video
for the first time and you watch and add
on it, statistically
it takes 1,000 new
views, this is statistics
like medieval. Um...
1,000 new views would make
a dollar, right?
It would
take
returning views
to make a dollar. Returning
views for some reason are so
much more expensive.
Especially in the ASMR side of things.
I'm gonna do shorts about it and show you
cause I was gonna do like a
clickbait short that's like
ah, how much the ASMR
can obviously show my income cause
um...
I fucking hate gatekeeping knowledge.
Um, so...
Now I'm missing this one.
Uh...
Oh there it is. Um...
Yeah, I was gonna
talk about all that. Oh my god, we have
a farm! Oh, we have
our little sprite ones and
our bobber sprite map.
That's so cute.
Oh my god, forget the farm, Arthur. We're just gonna
beg again.
The farm's already made, we just need to take over
it. What are they gonna do?
Shoot us?
Oh, look at
our crop harvest this year.
This one is so bountiful.
It's like coming together.
I don't want to jinx it, but
coming together.
Coming together.
That's why I hate you two.
Thank you so much for the tip.
It's very bizarre.
It doesn't click on an ad to give
extra revenue to.
It has to be legitimate.
Now, this is how bad that data tracking
and shit has gone.
If you were to, in theory,
click on ads on me all the time, but
no one else.
The algorithm fucking knows what you're
up to and will not
null and void it.
So, obviously, don't do that.
I'm not telling you to do that.
I'm not sure that can get you.
Right, I need
eight poopies.
It's just
I didn't care what's going on with that ASMR.
Literally, it's the
top ten searches
and they're trying to...
I don't know if it's just like a public
action thing and the rules have caught up
because the public deem ASMR
p-yop corny.
But,
obviously, if you're someone who consumes ASMR
you know it's not pop corny.
It's only pop corny
if you listen to the pop corny
side of it. You know what I mean?
That's when
it's...
Am I supposed to stick around?
No.
I better not be paying attention.
It's like
anything. You can type in
a toaster online
and it's wholesome.
But, if you type in
a toaster doing a backflip on the B
then, obviously, you're going to get a
toaster doing a backflip on the B.
But, unfortunately,
YouTube has deemed
pretty much the default
of ASMR to be
and their new
AI on it has been
running a Mac.
Running a Mac, I tell you.
ASMR isn't always.
No, it's literally
fucking choose your player. Oh, you chose
the this? Okay.
But, now, we will all punish him.
What is this?
I'm making a bench that he smokes
on!
Wait, is this the sticker?
I'm to put
the bench stickers on this?
I'm
a bit nervous to
am I?
Is that what that means?
Is it?
Or is it trying to tell me
it's a bench? No,
these are not...
Hmm...
Well,
you know what? If it is a bench, I can stick
it on. So, actually,
whoa, these are too long.
Hmm...
I need big
building, big thinking.
It's literally so hard for me
to talk and do this at the same time.
I'm so sorry if you feel a bit ignored
in chat today. I do apologize.
I'm trying to glance up every so often.
But, like, unironically,
the longer I glance up,
the more
I'm going to be
taking longer. And I feel like you guys
have been really patient and I want to polish
the stream off. I want to polish
the stream off.
So I can enjoy it.
I'll take a picture of it
finished with my ass in the back.
Are you squidding me right now?
Literally, that's how I make it up to you all the time.
I'm just like...
Oh.
It's cool? What?
To see how cool
this...
Sorry, I can't read that last
word that Brian said in that sentence.
Oh, there it is.
It's boring.
Thank you, tiny, tiny, for the kit.
This being the latest...
I think Flashcam is one of the
streamers I've ever been to, given it about to date.
I mean, no, I haven't fucking helped.
But, um...
What the fuck did I do now?
Right, and then do that.
And then put the bench down where?
This?
One, two, three, four,
from the grave. One, two, three,
and then on the fourth one
the bench begins.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's so cute!
Oh, I love it.
I love it.
It's so fucking cool, ain't it?
I love it. I love it. I love it.
Flower time!
Okay, come, come here though.
Right, what do we need? We need two red...
No, one red.
Two, wait.
One more ninja stars.
Starlight, ninja.
And then we need five stops.
Oh my god, this is just like the
Lego games.
I didn't know they did them like this.
And that's where the Lego games
got the easy thing from.
It's not about the end thoughts,
it's about spending time yapping.
I mean, if you don't mind the yapping,
I'm sure I'll take my time, but I just...
I feel like...
What the fuck?
Wait, how do I combine these? Hold on.
There's
four
flowers
in three holes.
Excuse me?
Not to rip these.
Uh...
Can you wake up?
I really go to fuck the suit.
Man, I'm having it anymore.
You're not staying up any longer every time.
Am I supposed to...
Am I supposed to detach these?
I am!
Okay, my apologies.
Am I?
I don't know.
I'm a bleeding heart.
I live for the only gap session.
But...
I'm not to peel these off.
Hold on.
Mommy's having a stroke.
You cannot evade her love for who you have.
Um...
I love you boys so much.
Oh, thank you.
Um...
Oh! Okay.
Ah.
Okay.
I fell watching.
I've been waiting.
From the shadows.
Come take me home.
I'm sorry about the shadow cast.
I hope that doesn't annoy anyone.
I literally don't know how to sleep.
Other than blending as old,
I opted not to.
Right, okay.
There's a flower...
Dog?
Okay.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
I'm going to cream my little palms with this.
Mommy's going to need that.
That is so cute.
Thank you so much for giving it to me.
I'm your little streamer dog.
Please, I'll do anything.
This is so nice. Thank you.
Coconut bombs.
Oh, uh...
Will there be a new member for Gen 2?
What?
You mean the six new girls in the next generation?
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, there's going to be a few more girls.
Thank you, Coconut.
For your...
Your monies.
Did I misunderstand what you asked?
Or did you not mean to ask that?
Good to know.
Wait, type in...
Did you accidentally say the wrong thing?
Oh, like how Gen 1's all me?
Oh, yes, I forgot about that.
Hi, Tata.
Did you like my DJing skills?
I can't wait to show you my poetry
because I actually didn't notice about Snowy.
Little Snowy Icy Pulse,
that she is creative like that.
I didn't know,
and I think her voice is extra adorable.
And I have no idea what kind of poetry
she has done,
but it seems like interest for her
which is extra-extra-ty.
Remember Risa?
They are all me.
Sorry about the donathon delay.
I am working very hard.
Actually, I will say one thing.
Someone messaged the website
and we were like,
where's my rewards?
We haven't started them yet.
We are waiting for the bleeding hearts
to finalize their names.
And then Azura is getting sent
a list of all the doodles she has to do,
so good luck to her in godspeed
because that's gonna suck for a while.
But she's gonna do really well.
And she's gonna do the kissing audio
and I'm in that I think.
Just for quickness's sake.
She's doing really well
tackling the donathon with her streams.
Although she's yapping,
speaking of yapping,
she's yapping so much
that she's not finishing her goal on stream,
which means it'll take longer
for it to be fulfilled,
which I'm trying to repeat them.
Sorry, sorry.
My hands went in the frame.
I'm trying to avoid repeating the mistakes
that we have seen from other agencies.
And like I'm actually about to propose
she these finalized donathons.
And if she agrees to it,
then in the wise words of the coconut,
let's get to it.
Shibi's also gonna be doing
some of her rewards in advance,
so I'll quit.
I'll see how it goes.
I think she's actually getting a new piece.
Mummy's proposing to Shibi.
I propose the thing,
the donathon.
Here's your award.
It's exciting because I've asked the girls,
I said, it really, it really does my go-in.
There, there's some scots for you.
It does my go-in when it is a donathon
and there's like big, massive gaps
in between my off-stones.
It hurts my soul so much.
I'm just like,
you can't think of anything
between 7,000 US dollars that you could do.
Not even a fucking quick ASMR.
Like, come on.
I'm so mad I didn't find Vela
until after the donathon.
Is that how you found her on her birthday?
That's nice, though,
that you got to find her at such a good time, though.
So she's gonna be moving out soon to you.
I don't know what the shirt you're wearing,
she knows.
Right, we need five poopy studs
and ten blocks,
which is all in here.
Blocks with a gap, see?
Blocks are good.
My eyes cannot see.
Right, let's do the poopy studs first
because those are super easy to identify.
Mia's sheevy's next,
and then I'm after sheevy
and then thankfully there's a big old gap
between anyone else at Vela
or something that does some creative things
behind the scenes,
and then I'll have to start preparing
for the other girls as well
and planning all their stuff for them,
making it super easy
because you need to enable your talents.
Hold on, I've got an eyelash on my eyeball.
I'm going down.
Mummy, are we gonna watch the trilogy of Austin?
I have no idea.
I don't know what I'm getting into
if I'm being honest.
I have no idea what I'm getting into.
What is that?
I genuinely cannot tell.
Sorry, I'm needing to look at it.
My glasses.
I can find my glasses
and I refuse to wear them
because I can't be bothered
going through the headache of the three days
it takes for your eyes to adjust.
My glasses.
We need ten of these ones.
We're getting there then.
We're cooking them.
You just listen to me.
No, not that one.
That's a whole.
Wait, how many is that?
Three, six, nine.
The goose drank wine.
The monkey's in the back.
Doing something.
You can't remember the words.
And then it's soil, soil, soil, soil, soil.
The poop's dead in the soil.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
One.
Two.
Oh, you can't see it.
Oh, no, you can.
Oh, jeez.
The fashion on my face.
Is that accident yet?
Or have I been behaving somehow?
Behaving.
I just knew it was going to be happening on the screen
and I was like, all right, here we go.
A long time, you see?
Yeah, I'm stressed.
Those are two.
No, you're being rude.
Come on, I'm bringing them.
Come on.
I was one of the slow responders.
Oh, you were a slow fucking responder.
There was like five people,
but management did a tweet
and they were like, bro, if you don't reply,
you're getting, we're just going to assume
you don't want the reward
because we actually, surprisingly,
got a few people replied back and said,
nah, yeah, I don't want anything.
Knock yourself out.
And I was like, oh, what an absolute child.
Which I found surprising because I'm like, oh, well,
I don't know if I can send a generic version
of the reward at least just to be like,
we've got something out of it because I mean,
shoot, you've fucking funded a zero moving out,
which is really big.
And it's not like a...
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I've knocked that over, that white flower.
Sorry, Mr. Flower.
Please go in the ground.
Please aim for the correct tile.
Thank you.
Well, we get the generic reward.
Yes.
And that was another thing.
I wanted them to be public rewards,
not like, these rewards only accessible first.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
And then I need to deal.
I have refunds that are members.
We'll do another membership stream about my donor fund
and we'll try and get it finalized
and then I can start working on the rewards
way before.
And because...
I'm gonna be a mighty king
so enemies beware.
I've never seen a king or two
with quite so little hair.
And I'd be the man of the...
man of the forest.
I'm looking at the brush with paint
I'm working on my life
Everybody looks right
Wherever I'm standing
I'm standing spotlight
Oh, sorry, I'm off on one.
How are we looking?
Literally makes a woman seem...
true, leaves, honestly.
Well, I've had enough.
I'm just pissed at PayPal
because you weren't using email.
Oh, I don't want to, I don't want to.
We're not actually, like, impatient towards anyone
or anything for that matter.
That's not...
block and then knob.
Block, knob, stud.
What a combo.
Bit of a block, bit of a knob and a bit of a dot.
Like, why is that?
It's just sick.
I'm standing.
Accurately.
Sorry, if you heard my stomach there,
it sounded like I farted.
If I thought I'd eat, I should.
Yeah, I might eat more.
Sorry, my brain's starting to get a bit quiet.
Come back, brain roll.
At least you were saying stuff.
No, brain roll, please.
Please, I'll be a good girl.
I'll be a good girl, please.
You're the only reason I could talk right now
because I'm trying to fucking do two things at once.
And it's too much for my brain.
Okay.
Come back.
Please.
I'm gonna learn from Viagra.
Why is that the first...
What? Call it a bonathon?
Okay, that's not the first one yet.
Welcome to my bonathon.
Everything is...
Bokuwa set.
Oh my god.
We still have all of this one to go as well.
I think I'm gonna keep going,
but if it gets to really pernickety details
that aren't a thing,
I might just wrap it up.
Wrap it up.
Because my brain's getting tired
and my tongue's hunched.
And my hands are cold
and I'm on my knees
looking for the answers
all the way through
If I fuck you again.
No, I'm not fucking fucking...
Sometimes.
Oh.
Common.
You'd rather call it your mum,
I wouldn't mind if I were eating that.
I don't know.
I'm kind of blitzing through a few of the pages.
And...
I just don't...
I don't want to be left unsatisfied.
I don't want you to have blue balls, okay?
I mean, we're so close to greatness.
So close.
I need smooth beans.
Just like my head.
I have two long...
Okay, that's what I need.
Two long beans.
One smooth wee beans.
Smooth wee beans.
Smooth.
Whacked.
But it's just this petan.
Okay, we love petan.
You need to get a deal of bone too.
I was fricking raging, by the way.
I fucking bought the collars at full price
and then the company that I bought them for
were like, here's a code for 50% off.
I'm like, I could have fucking used that
before the order, you twat.
I know, obviously, just like,
it just shows you how much of a markup they have
because they'll still make a profit
after that 50% is taken off.
And I'm like, how much do they get fucking scum ass?
Honestly.
Honestly, mate.
Right, this is definitely stickers
I'm supposed to be putting on.
I don't think I have the accuracy for stickers.
Well, I do now, apparently.
I've fucking done it now.
Hold on.
I've done it now.
Can I put that back on?
Yeah, I'm gonna just put that one back on
because what have I done?
Okay, this is a long sticker,
so let's take that one.
Okay.
Ten years, this has been waiting to be
stuck onto something.
Don't fuck it up,
do you understand?
Ow!
No, don't fuck it up.
Don't fuck it up.
Don't put your...
your video up something.
Oh my god.
Oh?
Okay.
Shit.
Okay, hold on.
No!
How is anyone supposed to...
Oh, this is my last time.
Hold on.
This is like surgery, okay,
but we were...
We're coming.
Oh.
Shit.
That'll do.
I do not care that much.
What the fuck?
Am I actually...
Like that?
Okay, give me another shot, I don't know.
Okay, put it in the right hand,
because your right hand is for one.
And then steady your approach.
Okay.
Whoa!
Not bad, almost perfect.
Almost frame perfect, I'm not kidding.
That was not bad, that one.
Rest well, those who sleep.
That one was...
That's not funny.
Don't tell anyone you're fucking driving off the road.
Okay, and then I put my fence together.
Wait, where did it start?
Here.
Do you know what it's mean?
No, it's just open.
Wait, what?
Hold on.
Oh, it comes over.
It doesn't go on this one.
Some...
I'm not moving.
There we go.
For role-playing purposes, the fence isn't actually a fence.
What is that?
Sorry, I just saw my face there.
I mean, it looks like a front garden.
I need you and Amy sing a fortnight battle pass.
Oh, I don't know if it's up here.
I think there was an update about...
Music guys, I'm so sorry.
I'm gonna hear my little sister sing.
And then this is only one.
Oh, no.
Put it in your right hand to do it.
Is it steady for Freddy?
Five nights at Freddy's.
There's only five nights at Freddy's game that came out.
That's called The Boar Pit.
It goes...
Wait.
There's a scan of...
I am what...
How do they say in English?
A fucking dipshirt.
Yeah, it's kind of good.
The end of the ball pit game?
Yeah, I've seen a lot of each of us jump on it.
I'm like, damn, does that mean it's accessible to dumbasses like me?
I'm happy to make music.
Normal.
Sensational.
I mean, it's messy.
I do.
Come on.
I guess I can be directly into them.
Pretty true.
I don't know if anyone can do it.
I need to start memorizing the schedules so I can be like,
Oh, this girl is playing this thing.
This girl is doing this thing.
Yeah, I know.
I need a hinge.
Are we hinge?
Then what about we hinge in here?
No, that's a bit...
A hinge?
Got a hinge.
What is that?
Okay, and then three flat ones.
One, two,
three,
and then two long sticks.
Two.
Well, well, well.
Amy's moving her female back.
Opinion on corner of the city.
I used to eat tons of roasted shreddies.
I wish they had them here, but they couldn't.
Honestly, I kind of need to move back to school.
Um,
the door,
I just go straight on like this.
I'm like, how am I going to break it?
Oh, I'm like, I love when there's like movable pieces.
Let me try that again.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I love when there's like movable pieces.
Yeah.
I shouldn't move that much, but there you go.
Immediately breaks the gate.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
I've got three flat,
three flat and two long.
What is that view?
What is that?
What is that doing?
Oh, it makes the fucking sense.
Okay.
Excuse me.
I'm a little less sensitive than it is.
One.
Yeah.
Yeah, work with me.
Work with me.
Okay.
I will have no one laughing at my fucked up.
And then just like snap it in like that.
Okay.
It's a real dance.
So then.
What?
Sorry.
I'm having to like the light and shine.
Okay.
I admit it.
The light and shine to put the fucking thing together.
Like, you can see,
I'm covering up the wee patches in the fence.
I mean,
isn't it more realistic to have a violent beast?
A violent beast.
Let's move that one.
Can you tuck it that way?
Okay.
There.
That's like a fence and a gate.
And like, it doesn't have to be perfectly straight.
It looks more authentic because it's all wobbly and stuff.
Okay.
Next.
Of.
All my fucking iPhones will die.
Bliet.
Bliet nachoi.
Puka.
I put my iPhone inside.
If you hear a din din din, that's me.
I told you that was me.
Don't know.
I'm still moving.
What are some foods from Australia that you feel like?
It's not that I don't like Aussie food.
It's just,
can when you eat a food type and it's always been that way,
like it's always been the way you've known it.
That's what I struggle with because I'm like,
this doesn't taste like,
like I can't even find fucking cookies that are nice here.
But it's not because the cookies are like,
bog in, ming in, absolutely XYZ elemental piece.
It's because I'm used to cookies being a certain way
and Aussies have stuff different ways.
And I'm like,
Oh my God.
Why is the
stalk so long?
It's like your pintas.
Your stalk is so long.
Yeah.
And then an apple.
Well, you have the apple in your bowl.
Okay.
Then what?
This goes here.
Did I fish it down?
I'll just let it sit there.
Fuck yeah.
Look, I ain't here trying to,
I'm not trying to force anything.
That doesn't want to be, you know,
like two coconuts.
You put the lime and the coconut.
Have you been able to hold it in the microwave?
Oh, is this sweet?
It's not sweet.
That's why we've got a spell on.
I've been eating,
my sweet is
um,
Stroopwafel.
There's like an imported Stroopwafel here.
And it's, um,
sorry, I just said it in my accent.
Oh,
equal,
ain't,
no, ain't,
equal in
Stroopwafel.
Else you bleefed.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
For the one doctor who's not looking for me.
Wait, what?
We're going back to inside.
Right. Okay.
What were they?
Step one.
Step two.
Oh, right.
Okay.
Sorry.
I've been like too distracted.
I'm to
put it.
Yeah.
Right.
In you comes the,
I should have done this at an angle.
And looking at what POV that you see versus like what I see.
I'm like, yeah,
I should have had a bit of a
different setup.
I apologize.
My theory was correct.
One sweet is important.
This content is too good not to subscribe for.
Oh,
thank you.
I'm glad you can enjoy me rambling into the void.
No, no,
please.
I'll be here all week.
Right.
Bench.
Little black things with a knob on it.
Little black thing with a knob on it.
Uh,
one
brown
two
things.
Got it.
Whatever the fuck that is,
you know what I mean?
What was that?
I don't have that.
My view.
My bird.
Again.
Oh, there is.
Okay.
Wrong color.
I was looking for a certain color.
I can see it.
Of course.
Me too strong in the picture.
I know.
I like,
savory,
like food wise.
Strip waffles,
like two really thin waffles with a layer of thick curry caramel.
Barbecue gator.
You're not eating gator.
Oh, there's kangaroo and the cat food here.
I was like,
he'll excuse you.
Right.
Inside,
like this.
I think of that.
Ow.
It's dragging me.
It's hurting me.
Okay, then put this in.
Okay.
Oh, Jesus.
What the fuck am I making?
His writing desk.
Oh,
I'm making Bilbo's writing desk.
that's so cute.
Oh,
that's so cool.
I just clocked.
Like,
this looks like his writing desk and then there's his contract to sign.
Oh,
please.
Please.
My fingers feel like they're falling off
or my little
index finger.
Although it looks like the same color.
It's like,
oh my other thing.
So I guess that cannae bean
have been that bad.
Can it have been?
Oh, come on.
Right.
Bilbo's writing desk is made.
Now what do I do?
I take a quill,
a bottle,
and the boot.
The boot.
I put
the stickers on,
but it must go a certain way.
I think
I already made it.
I can fall by doing it.
Let's be careful.
Yeah.
Open the book.
On the right side of the book,
place this sticker in the picture.
It's like surgery.
Beep.
I'll find the patient, please.
Oh, fuck.
Right.
It was going to rip
if I pulled it up.
You need to come at
or else it'll rip.
Right there.
How?
I don't even know how I made it.
There's actually,
but you saw that it worked.
This is
not when you bend it.
The way this diagram shows the book
closed.
The book cannot be closed.
I assure you that thing is not closed
and not for me,
not for anything else.
And then I need his
other,
his little writing glass.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
And then put the quill
on his new writing glass.
And then
take the
ticket, ticket.
I'm knuckling to myself again.
I miss my wife, please.
How did we do this?
Oh, no.
I fucked that book up.
How am I supposed to
close the book?
Am I missing something?
Other than brain cells,
am I missing something?
The book's not closed then.
Oh.
Is that breaking?
Oh, no.
I want to close it.
Oh.
Okay.
I guess because it's,
hmm.
I go.
I mean, I go.
I close.
I close the book.
Don't worry.
There's force.
There's such a man we fling.
Of course, the first thing you
would say is,
there's force.
What did that book?
Wait, where's the book?
There's a text.
Hello.
Oh.
Are you squidding me right now?
Yeah.
Deep fried Cajun seasoned
gator tail is a delicacy.
gator tail is a delicacy?
Oh, yeah.
Thank you, David.
Hmm.
Uh.
Lime on Easter
tend to make sense.
She's a fucking liar.
Okay.
Let me finger this in that place.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Come on, baby.
He's gonna make me cry.
Oh, no.
No, stop breaking.
I can hear stuff breaking back there.
Stop it.
Stop breaking.
Right, that's it.
Where's that orange thing?
Is it the carrots?
Right, go to the,
go to the stage
and think about what you're doing.
You're stressing me out.
No.
Don't start this up.
Go and be a good fan.
Hold on.
I need a moment to,
I need a moment to think.
Do I know what to think of?
Please, please hold on.
Yes.
And like click, no.
Right.
What's the problem?
Why are you counting the balance?
Go.
Right.
No.
I just bumped my head on the window.
Hold on.
Lift.
Okay.
And right.
Fuck the quill.
No one's bothered about it.
Press down gently on Bilbo's
writing desk
to link it
to the fucking table.
Just, what?
Right.
That's it.
The table's coming with me.
I was being nice,
but you've done it now.
I was being,
I was being nice,
not fucking come up.
I was being nice.
Right.
You, you're fucking down.
This.
That's it.
That's all I wanted.
Jesus.
I can't do it.
That's all I wanted to do.
There.
Are you happy?
Shoot.
Well,
evil day.
Evil, evil.
Okay.
And then put his quill down.
I have to get these nails off of me.
I'm ripping them out.
Like,
what's that?
Damba anime.
Cagaguri.
Ripping my nails out like cagaguri.
Oh, come on.
All right.
And then.
Oh.
Right.
It's done.
Bilbo's wee corner set up.
Now what?
I'm making a dining table.
The entrance to the house.
Mummy's getting tired, babies.
Mummy's ready for a nap,
but not in a mean way.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
If I continue,
it looks like it's just a,
what, a grass verge.
I literally don't.
Oh, it's the roof of the house.
Oh, there's a tree on it.
Oh, we're so close.
Right.
No.
Hold it together.
I can't laugh yet.
Hear me, baby.
Hold it together.
Okay.
Relax.
Everything's fine.
Everything's cool
when you party to tea.
Right.
We're going to take out the time bricks
and we're going to do the front door area.
And
maybe I can do it.
I don't know.
I'm tired.
I'm so fucking exhausted.
All I do.
Oh, my God.
Streamer is tired,
building Lego.
Look how entitled these streamers are.
They're so out of touch with reality.
I can't believe it.
These streamers,
these streamers would know what hard work was
and if it hit them in their,
in their face.
Sorry.
I'm going to,
I'm a shadow,
but mommy,
they're really, really good.
I'm called Desperate.
Just remember this tip.
If the gumbo recipe tells you to use potatoes,
it's blind.
You know what I thought?
Gumbo was like shrimp potatoes and best.
Shawnee, take a break.
We can do another day.
You're over a spring.
No, it's not going to.
Going down without a fight.
A feature for being out of touch.
Never.
Honestly.
This is all for male attention.
I actually don't,
like,
Lord of the Rings.
Could you imagine if I didn't know?
I secretly hate Lord of the Rings.
I hate everything about it.
I hate,
I hate the way that good prevails,
prevails evil.
I hate the way that even in the bad,
there is good,
i.e. golem.
I hate the way
that there's a well thought out fantasy
and even against,
oh wait a minute.
There's in game racism in Lord of the Rings
isn't there?
The elves in the dwarves.
Knife ears.
What is it,
what would a dwarf insult the
beard face?
Ah, the way you have a beard.
Oh my god.
Ah.
What a beard.
You're beard.
Ah, beard.
Like what?
How do you insult a dwarf?
I swear if I turn around
and read the word manlands.
Okay, no one did.
You're actually well behaved.
A four hour building stream
for male attention,
literally suffering through it
although I do feel vindicated
every time someone says
that they like the stream.
For anyone who's new and lurking
by the way,
this is a massive meme
in between me and my community.
I will happily repeat the story
before you're like,
what?
I'm unsubscribing right now.
So someone asked me,
in another life,
they were like,
why do you play video games?
And I was like,
I didn't know what to respond to
it because I'd never been asked
that before.
I was like,
I just play video games.
But he was asking
why I a girl play video games.
And I was like,
what are you on about?
Like,
like,
you know,
instead of being like girls
play games all the time,
you just don't know,
they're all like not talking in
chat because of harassment
etc.
or whatever.
And I,
I sarcastically said,
and I don't know what
possess me do this,
but I sarcastically said,
I do it for male attention.
And he accepted that answer.
He didn't question it.
He didn't like have a ha ha.
He went, okay.
And that was it.
That was the end of the conversation.
And I'm like,
so unsubscribed literally,
literally.
And I was like,
so now the running gag is like,
I only stream for male attention.
I only do stuff for male attention.
And,
and that's what we're
meaning about when we say
I only do stuff for male attention.
Cause
that was
an eye-opener.
It was like, oh,
that's right.
People can't help
sarcasm.
Wow.
That bottle
isn't in this packet again.
There's no bottle
in the bowl,
in my bowl.
That's interesting.
That bottle isn't here
in the other packet as well.
Curious.
Seriously.
Mummy,
where's my check?
The paid attorney's payment.
I don't forget about
the pre-recorded streams either.
Wait,
I've been playing with girls
online for all these years.
Oh yeah,
there is,
I can assure you
there is so many more
growth.
Oh wait,
if you're being serious
for a second,
I'll be serious back.
What on that?
The seats
are one off of the
fireplace?
One
here?
And
if you're being,
if you want to be serious
for a second,
yes,
there's like
a kabillion
gamer grills.
Can you
fucking rotate the
P.O.V.
you're giving me right now?
I honestly
look like it's
one, two.
They're two apart.
Is it possible?
I don't know.
It looks like it lines up
with a fire.
Well,
it's a shame
because it goes over to
Bilbo's writing desk,
which is not
particularly
what I'm
interested in.
What is that?
Oh,
the underside of it.
Yes,
I cannot tell you
how many games
actually have girls in it
and the only reason
they don't talk
is because there's not
another girl that starts,
but I,
well,
I used to
when I used to play games.
I know,
I used to play for
male attention
all those years ago.
Am I losing it?
Do you not
slot in here?
Am I?
This is supposed to be
there?
Of course.
And I,
so you know what I'm
surprised you guys
don't have makes talk with
when we stream
snipe each other.
The reason I'm
surprised is because
the way I play video games
is I always say,
good morning,
good luck,
have fun type thing.
Or like,
if it's an after,
if it's afternoon,
say good afternoon,
good luck in the game.
Hope everyone has
fun type thing.
I'm that kind of gamer.
So when you
are like,
oh,
are my purple?
I'm like,
oh,
how do you,
how do you communicate?
How do you say
there's an animal over here?
Oh,
sorry,
I'm talking over Brian.
Bear questions,
why wouldn't you play video games?
I feel like,
I feel like
you have to be
forbade to play the,
I forbade you.
What do you mean you're
forbade me?
I'm playing video games.
Stache Power,
thanks for the tip.
The better question,
why wouldn't you play them?
Because games are like,
you know,
they're immersive.
Yeah.
I remember
the classic music
I like to play video games.
Mm-hmm.
I like them,
I like them when it comes to video games.
Yeah.
Again,
I don't,
I don't have this bottle.
It's asking for that bottle diagram.
This does not exist
in my itinerary.
So I guess we're just getting
out of the table here.
Um,
hold on,
someone,
the fish is running away.
Uh,
my lightbulb.
I never talk ever except from women.
Girls in my video games,
I don't play the new thing.
I'm a league player,
so it's pink.
I have a mic,
but you haven't played a game.
I can play,
I also don't
want to be a male on stream.
I don't think we male
on stream each other.
Really?
I don't think we do.
Yay!
Come on.
Hmm.
I'm sorry for the tracking
on my model being so weird as well.
I can't,
uh...
Oh!
Mm-hmm.
Hmm?
Where did you just spawn those suits?
Oh.
Okay, sorry.
Um...
I mean,
why did it spawn
on a few seats without
my instructions?
That's not...
Eee,
Strony on stream,
what the fuck is this?
I don't know,
I find it fun when we get
to talk to each other.
Am I weird?
Is that me,
parasocial for you?
I just interest in,
like, hearing your voices
or like,
when you're like,
oh, thanks for the game, Strony.
I'm like,
I don't know,
maybe I'm just weird
and obsessive,
and not with him.
We've got a streamer
that actually likes
our community.
A streamer that actually
wants to hang out with us.
What?
I've never heard
of the likes before.
Well,
a streamer that knows
how to gate-cape themselves,
but I didn't use some more.
You're Yapaqua!
As the French say,
welcome,
Yapaqua.
What can I say?
Sorry,
I'm often one.
I play Dota,
but I'm sorry,
we can never stream site.
Also,
it would be
disturbing if someone would
recognize my voice.
Is it bad that
sometimes I try
and link up your voices?
I don't know,
it is nice.
Maybe I was the
Yandere all along.
I don't mean it in a
weird way,
I don't know.
If you want to lurk,
you can lurk-y-poo.
Hopefully,
you don't feel any stress
or pressure from me,
because like,
you know,
do anything
out of your comfort zone.
You can always,
always, always
just chill with me,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna force you
to do anything.
Well,
you need our voice queen.
That's terrible.
Please don't say that
out loud again,
okay, I'm sorry.
Here?
There it is,
it's here.
Why is it randomly speaking?
It's
telling me to put the seats
in,
which I just did.
I've just done the chair,
so I need
a bit of sand
and the mat.
Why, of course,
the mat?
The one that I'm totally
not gonna mess up right now.
I think of that.
That's funny,
my great queen,
no,
don't start that.
We could actually
get in trouble for that one.
I think that's funny
when you guys do it,
when you hear your fantasies
or whatever,
like,
you know how it's like,
oh, that's naughty,
that's bad,
that's how it makes it
like more enticing?
Does that make sense?
Because we know we're not
supposed to like joke about it,
and we know we're not supposed
to like fantasise about it,
but it like seems to make it
ten times funnier.
What's some of your worst
experiences being
a chick,
a demon?
I had someone
cause I didn't pocket,
like cause I didn't do
their bidding as a tank,
he basically like
was screaming down the make
that I'm an R word
because I'm a girl
and like all of that.
Like I was pretty nasty
and I was like really surprised
about it,
cause I was like,
no, you're just a really shit DPS.
If you need a tank,
I was diva,
I still remember it,
he was soldier
and he was getting pocketed
by his healer,
he was slain.
And I just got absolutely
cussed at it.
I had a guy throw a game
because I figured out
I was a girl as well,
I remember that one,
I was a Rissa,
and I just spoke
and I was like,
oh, good morning,
good luck in the games,
hopefully,
you know,
it looks like the enemies
are XYZ,
cause I used to go
into their spawn
and see who
was selected and all that
and the guy was like,
oh, girl, I'm thrown,
and he just stopped playing
and I was like,
oh, well.
I do remember the nasty one,
and don't you learn
curse words
in about 10 languages
if he does that on wrong?
Is it Reaper mains
or the worst?
I mean,
obviously I don't play anymore,
so you forget
the bad interactions
over time,
but you know when you have
like a really bad one
and it was like,
you know when you walk away
and you're like,
wow, that person had
like a genuine hatred
towards me
and I literally
was just playing a video game,
like I was just mucking
about having fun,
I mean, you've heard me
on Overwatch,
I'm screaming,
I'm hootering,
I'm hollering,
like I'm just having
like a goofy time
or whatever,
you can imagine
like if someone turns
around and is like,
you should,
you know,
do-do-do-do-do,
do-do-do-do,
like all of this stuff
because like I was born into,
you can imagine my surprise
where I'm like,
oh, okay,
like it's a complete mood changer
and you do remember
the bad ones, like,
I mean,
you guys have already kind of
heard the stories like,
oh,
chick gamers,
you get a bit of harassment
and I mean,
I'm not going to fucking
dwell on it,
I'm just like,
yeah, I get harassment,
but I'm still alive.
Yeah, it sucks,
but does that,
is that going to stop me
from like playing,
I suppose that's the question
you have to ask yourself,
is it
so bad
that you genuinely
don't want to play
video games after
and like,
the answer is not,
like,
you'll survive,
it's not pleasant,
don't get me wrong,
I'm not fucking saying,
I'm not saying suck it up,
but I'm saying like,
if you're only going to remember
the bad,
then yeah,
no shit,
gaming is going to be
like a horrible,
stressful experience
for you
if you're going to focus in
on the bad,
but,
I mean,
if you heard me in
vermin tide
and overwatch,
like,
where I'm goofing off,
everyone's being so nice,
I've not had anyone,
you know,
stream snake me
and say anything nasty,
like,
it's just a hoot
and a holler,
and,
it's all the good stuff,
like,
it's nice being able to
just play,
and be gamers,
like,
I know I'm not like
the strongest gamer,
I enjoy video games,
and,
I enjoy the,
the,
is it medium?
Medium?
Put that baguette on the table,
you know,
French up in here.
Okay.
I guess I can put the
wine glasses down.
Oh,
the one wine glass
that's given me.
Okay,
I'll put that.
Oh wait,
no,
the wine glass
is already on the table.
Oh,
is that the ball?
It's an upside down glass?
Oh,
it appears my
particular strength in me.
A pretzel?
Oh my gosh,
look,
I've got three holes for you,
just like a pretzel.
You're welcome.
You can use that anytime.
Okay,
it's medium.
To be honest,
you're a little too hyper
and over much.
Nah,
I enjoy playing video games.
Uh,
see how many left over?
A random boom handle?
What am I supposed to do?
Like,
what am I supposed to do with it?
I don't know.
Uh,
the next part is just the roof.
Are we bothered about the roof right now?
I tell you what,
can I make
the rest of the party?
And then
I actually like that
the back of the
thing is open.
I like how the roof is open.
And then we can role play inside.
Right,
I'll make the rest of the party
and we can deal.
And then I'm going to do
what I need to do.
Oh,
my ankle,
I don't know if you heard that.
Right,
so where was this other ball
supposed to go?
Was it supposed to go here?
In the corner.
The roof looks like something
you could do off stream.
Is that allowed?
I'm going to go for a nap
and I'll rest up.
I'm up.
You know,
fuck it,
we'll put two bottles
on the table then.
You heard that crack?
Yeah,
that was my ankle.
We are lining
because I'm sitting on it.
Okay,
same as before,
big leafling.
Pieces go in this one
and I'll do it off stream
and then
and finish it
like a good grill.
As you are,
my witness.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Me like,
oh,
I'll just,
oh no,
the grass.
Can you please,
please join us,
please join us.
No,
no,
I assure you
we want your part of the house.
Oh,
no,
don't do that.
Oh,
it's scared.
No,
no,
please join back.
Okay,
yeah,
and then over a bit.
Yeah,
it's not something
hmm.
What have I done?
Like that.
Okay.
Yeah,
that looks right.
Then what is it?
I'm afraid mommy's a bit patina right now.
Okay, that'll look much more like it.
Okay, that'll look more like it.
Okay, thank you for the mention.
Yeah, I'd say something controversial before.
The house is a bit janky for the price.
I don't know what the actual retail price was when it came out.
That's a whole other kettle of fish.
Can I get the rest of the part in yet?
Wait, how is there chicken here?
Did I not put chicken on the table?
Oh, you're flying out.
I feel like these Lego sets are like once you've built them, you can never look at them.
Or they're just going to like...
So we need Dualen.
There you go.
And Bomber.
Dualen and Bomber.
It's very interesting that they didn't put everyone in it.
I didn't eat that part, so...
Wait, is that Gandalf's stick?
Did Gandalf have a stick?
Oh, hold on.
Be careful.
I believe this is the walking stick.
That one's yours.
Okay, thank you.
And then...
Can I have some legs, please?
Oh, a friend pair.
Is that Dualen's?
It looks like a...
It looks like a Dualen's.
Depends on the set. Some are good to look at.
That was a good idea.
Gandalf literally loves his lovely stuff.
He's a fake fan sometimes, honestly.
Proof that I do it for male attention.
Okay, I must be in this packet.
Why would his legs be in this?
Ah, it is. A part of his body's in here.
Okay, let's get him out.
Is that a sausage?
Is this for Bomber?
No, the item he holds is a fucking sausage.
Okay, and then...
Nine?
Who's nine?
One is... Oh, one for Bomber and one for Dualen.
Hmm, okay.
I've seen those YouTube videos where people have a massive, massive, massive...
Nethin' is all he says.
Where's the prompt to press the button and hold so often?
Honestly?
Honestly, no.
Right, let's...
He only has one face, which looks disgruntled.
Okay.
Roots.
Right, let's... Where the fuck...
Alright, there's his chest.
Okay, that is both.
Hair and beard, which is...
separate in casing because it's so special.
I can't even do it.
Are you kidding me? I have, like, fucking weapons on my...
end of my fingernail, and I...
There we go. There we go.
I did, I did.
Hmm?
I never watched Lord of the Rings, but I know Gandalf has a big stick
because he's the one that says,
You shall not...
You've not seen it?
Well, my fucking presents to you.
I know what you're doing, I'm just...
I'm being forced to...
watch...
Lord of the Rings.
We do trading places.
I think I was going to do a lot of streams,
but I'm interested in our purchases,
so we can...
Oh, come on.
Um...
Yes, I'm streaming on Krimis and Balcony,
and the other day I set up
some free presents.
Yeah, okay.
This is...
looking a bit...
Why does it look...
not quite right?
Something's not quite right,
Oh!
He's bald!
Please take the sausage.
One...
One!
Please take the sausage!
Okay.
Okay, now put your...
It looks like he's slightly looking the wrong way.
That looks so wrong.
Okay, that'll do.
Cheese!
Okay, now we do this thing.
See, why don't they not have that for all the capes?
That's just super easy to do.
I mean...
So cool, isn't it?
Mm-hmm.
Oh!
Oh, he's halfway across the mountain.
Oh wait, he has beard?
Of course he has a beard.
And why would he put the beard on him?
Because that would have been too easy.
Wait, what's the back of his beard?
Hold on, I'm a fake fan, clearly.
Sorry to all of them.
Oh, no, mine mustn't be there.
Ah!
Come on, unexpected gathering,
unexpected tune.
That looks right.
Where's your weapon, then?
Time to assemble it.
Your fucking weapon?
Where's it, like, a pre-made piece?
I don't...
see his weapon.
I think I have to mute it.
Ugh, that's just too much effort, isn't it?
Mm-hmm.
Ah, I'm not late in the day for that,
don't you think, Dwellin?
I'm struck from your weaponry.
Okay.
Oh, careful.
Oh!
Excuse me, sorry.
You're pulling.
Mm-hmm.
And then the nape, right?
I don't know why they didn't separate me,
they're mounting me.
Ugh.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's gonna have a freaking nape on this one.
And then, who has the other nape?
Oh, it just depends who you want to roleplay with.
Okay, we'll fit the knife in the...
in the, um, this.
Okay, a knife in there.
So he's gonna be eating his sausage at the table
because he really has to.
Can I get him to sit down here?
Wait, what, Lego butts?
Don't Legos not have butts to sit down in?
Okay, I guess he's at the table eating.
Then Bilbo is gonna be at the door, like, with it open?
Right.
No.
Actually, can he hold it?
Oh, I just, oh, sorry.
Put that back on right now.
Eh, right, knives are off because everyone's,
everyone's just chilling.
Knives are down.
So I put a glass in the...
I'm at the wall in which I'm in.
Balan?
Balan's hand.
Because he's only having a glass.
He's like, oh my God, it's so nice to see.
Oh, right, he's off.
And then, ah, he's gonna be at the door when he went
and he's already taken it off.
And then he's gonna...
Yes, I'm playing with Lego.
Isn't this what I'm supposed to do?
The legs bend, doesn't it?
I've having...
I have terrible news.
These do not bend.
Is yours then?
These are non-bendable.
Have I been scummed?
Is this fake Lego I've been playing with from the last tour?
I don't think so.
I'm awful.
Okay.
And then he...
Oot molly.
Oot molly, ya bam.
Where did it go?
The map, there it is.
He's gonna be holding the map.
Where did he go?
Right, there you are.
Right, hold the map.
Hold it.
In between your fingers, please.
I'm trying to role-play here.
How can I role-play?
You're not literally holding it.
Surely they designed it to be held.
Okay, I'll take that.
Right, so he's at the door and he's like,
Oot molly.
And he's like,
Oh my god, brother, it's been so long.
Okay, I can't turn him that way.
And then Gandalf and Buffer are obviously just
pinching the dungeon man.
He's like,
Oh, you didn't part an old man with his walking stick, right?
And obviously not.
So Gandalf is the overseeing of everything at the party
because it's the unexpected party.
He's like at the edge overseeing it.
And he's like laughing.
He's like,
Oh, Christmas.
And then Buffer at the front smoking up that zaza.
He's blowing bubbles, blowing zaza.
I think they're there for...
Now don't, right.
Oh, choose.
Ray, I think we've done it.
I think we've done it.
Who was that?
I was the baguette.
Oh, not that right now.
Stay on the table.
Okay.
Glue everything down.
So Buffer's out at the front smoking the zaza.
Okay.
Not bad.
And you come in through the gate.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
He's coming through the gate.
And then the door opens.
The door shuts.
Are they in the way?
Oh, no.
There's fallen apart.
Right.
No.
I'm playing very quickly with it.
We're falling apart.
Help, help.
Okay.
And then we go and say...
And then we have the lovely...
Okay.
The food's gone everywhere, but it's okay.
I'll fix it in a minute.
Okay.
No.
Right.
And then when you come in, Bilbo is talking to Dwellin and he's got the map and he's like,
bro, this is what we're doing.
This is the mission.
And he's like, and what's this got to do with me?
I'm just a hobbit and back in, bro.
And he's like, no, I'm serious.
Look at all this.
And they're looking at the map together and that.
And then...
Bilbo's just super happy to see him because they're related, if you didn't know.
Bumba.
It's not Bumba.
Bombers.
Bombers eating away, honestly.
And then that's his little right in here.
And then that's the lovely fireplace with a frying pan.
Food and a broom.
And then...
We don't have a roof yet.
Okay, we need some more due to the roof.
Ma, thank you for the five gifted memberships and congrats to those who cut away your face.
Hobbits clearly didn't build their houses very well.
No, these...
I mean, it's alright.
If you ignore the fact that there's food all over the floor.
I think we did alright.
That was really hard and I'm never doing that again.
If you're wanting a Lego stream, we're literally doing pieces for three year olds.
That was for nine and fourteen year olds and I couldn't even finish it.
And how long?
Five and a half hours.
No wonder I'm tired.
Sorry, I should have been napping long ago.
Wait, hold up.
Let me...
Change your...
Oh.
Oh, my body's sore as well.
Hold on.
No, I can't laugh yet.
Okay.
Hi, I can see you now.
Hello, sir.
Hello.
Do you like...
What do you think about my...
My doll?
My doll? No.
My Lego set.
Now set on it?
Setting on it? That took me far too long.
I'm not setting on that.
I'm not even breaking it for the funny ha ha tee hee.
There's absolutely no way out.
No way.
Mummy, the noises you made while you were running your fingers through the night.
Hi.
Are you okay?
Are you having good time?
Good time.
Thanks again, Master, the five gifted members of...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Crazy streamer talks to herself for five hours.
I'm sweating right now.
It's Goshi.
Thank you for the extended membership.
Congrats on the build, Mummy.
It was a great stream.
I know it looks like it was really fun.
Love you.
Love you to me, Flynn.
Actually, it looks good.
It's too bad the food can't be pinned down.
Yeah, I think people glue their Lego sets.
Can you hot glue my Lego set?
It was a relaxing stream.
This is probably the calmest stream I've ever done.
I'm nothing but peace and tranquility right now.
Emmy's up on a...
Emmy's up streaming, so I'll redirect into Emma's.
Okay, she's playing Wizard 101.
I think you can stream like that if I'm not mistaken.
That set is old.
Well, that's why the legs don't bend.
How old is this?
I don't know how old that set is.
Hmm.
It chills me.
I hope it wasn't too boring.
I'm like, whoa, what, like, I'm not a disappointment.
This song came out three hours ago.
Oh, I did it.
The Christmas fucking night.
For tonight, man, I'll pay him.
I just shit.
Come on, Emma.
Can you show different angles of the Lego set up?
Hmm.
I showed it, did I not?
Not really, hold on.
Oh, my truck ain't gonna get lost yet.
The food's gonna go everywhere.
So, like, this is them in the parking.
And, like, this is the front.
Ignore all the weapons going everywhere.
I can't really, like, fit it sideways.
The set came out in 2012.
Oh, yeah.
We did it.
I'm excited to see them.
Oh, there goes the weaponry.
Hmm.
Not every stream has to be high up here.
Me is into egg mushrooms this week.
Oh.
Are you guys gonna be okay?
Did I do the roller thing yet?
Or did I not do it?
I'll forget to do it.
I've lost my role.
Well, it's over for us.
It's over.
Okay, I'm gonna redirect into MRIs.
I'm gonna say I love you.
I'm sorry, I'm a little sleepyhead right now.
How many kisses?
For how many party members there are?
Mwah, mwah, mwah.
Six.
There's only six of them.
Mwah, mwah, mwah.
I'm sorry, I'm a sleepyhead today.
Put it this way.
I thought the stream was gonna be two hours long.
I did not expect that.
I did not expect that at all.
Let's read our little sister.
Okay, you got a deal.
Let me make sure...
It's definitely gonna read our acting to her
because it annoys me when it says it's gonna, but it doesn't.
Yes, I will have a very good nap.
Thank you.
I see you tomorrow for some shenanigans.
What are we doing tomorrow?
What's going on tomorrow?
What am I doing tomorrow?
Chain together solo and then Austin powers.
Okay, deal.
I can do that.
Yes, I can do that.
I've got a kiss for every leg.
I'll be here forever.
Okay, please enjoy Emmy.
I'm sorry for quite a fast ending.
I'm gonna lie down.
I'm sleepy, baby.
I might be mummy, but sometimes I need baby too.
Okay, I see you tomorrow.
Have a good day.
Make sure to hydrate and sleep.
And sleep if you need it, okay?
See you in dreamland if enough, but the same time as me.
Bye-bye.
See you later, honey.
Till tomorrow.